EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IF SOCIAL TO. IT
FACE COVERING GOD IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS STATE HAS MADE
IT THAT'S THE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS THE NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT A REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
YOU'LL PLEASE WAIT ON THE SCREEN
AND ALL DOUBTS IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS FOU SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
. ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR STYLE
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAY
. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS DURING THE
LATE OF REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS. A CLEANING
PROTOCOL. THE COMMITTEE CARE ME
INTO. TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
THE COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW FOR TO
MAIN WITNESSES PER. IT WILL
LIMIT EACH WITNESS TO TWO
MINUTES. WE'LL BE KEEPING TRACK
OF TIME SO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
BRIEF. ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT COM TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION. AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. I WILL MAINTAIN
THE CALL. DURING THE HEARING IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. YOU DID
. WE HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS ON THE
TODAY'S AGENDA- IT AND IT DOES
NOT APPEAR THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
AT THIS TIME SO WE'RE GONNA
START IS SUBCOMMITTEE. AND IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION TO THAT-
WILL GO AHEAD AS PLANNED- WILL
BE WELL WE CAN'T DO THAT SO
WILL- BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB NINE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAT. MORTY CENTER PANDA
BEGIN GOOD MORNING THANK YOU AND
CHAIR- SENATORS- I PRESENT TO
YOU SENATE BILL NINE AWAIT WHICH
IS A MEASURE CREATED BY STUDENTS
TO UP LIFT OTHER STUDENTS I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON THE BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
FOR A FIVE YEAR SUNSET. THE
CIVICALLY SB NINE AWAIT WILL
INCREASE TO REPRESENTATION AT
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
EDUCATION BY ESTABLISHING A
THIRTEEN MEMBER. YOUTH ADVISORY
COMMISSION UNDER STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
NEARLY SIX MILLION STUDENTS AND
ALL OF THEM HAVE DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES AND PERSPECTIVES
THAT COULD IMPROVE OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. HOWEVER ONLY ONE STUDENT
IS CURRENTLY REPRESENTING ALL
SIX MILLION STUDENTS ON THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND IT'S CHALLENGING FOR THAT
ONE STUDENT TO ADEQUATELY
REPRESENT ALL THE STUDENTS WHO
UNIQUE NEEDS. THAT IS WHY THE
COMMISSION ESTABLISHED UNDER
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE STUDENTS
COME FROM EVERY REGION AND ARE
SELECTED BASED ON THEIR PASSION
EXPERIENCE RATHER THAN JUST A
GREAT. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO SPEAK TO A BROAD
RANGE OF ISSUES INCLUDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH BUT VIOLENCE
BULLYING OTHER ISSUES AFFECTING
STUDENTS. NOW MORE THAN EVER IS
IMPORTANT WE ELEVATE THE VOICES
OF STUDENTS THROUGH SB NINE
AWAIT SO THAT WE CAN POWER THEM
TO SOLVE THE ISSUES MOST
IMPORTANT TO THEM. JOINING ME
TODAY VIA TELECONFERENCE ARTS TO
STUDENTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS.
CATHERINE SHU AND ME NOT LYNN
LEE. BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER AND- BUT I ASKED THAT
MY TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TOP.
THE TESTIFIED THANK YOU SENATOR
PAM NOW MOVE ON ANYONE WANTING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- CATHERINE
CHU IN ME TO LEAD. YOU DETERMINE
WHO'S GONNA GO FIRST AND YOUR ON. THE MORNING CARE DOT AND
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATHERINE. AND I'M A SENIOR.
OUTLETS LIKE HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
CLARABELLE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I AM HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
OF THE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
POLICY DIRECTOR DEMONSTRATE OUR
SUPPORT AND SPONSORING SB NINE
AWAIT. BRIEFLY REITERATE THE
BILL AT UNITED WE CREATE A
STUDENT BY THREE COMMISSION
UNDER THE STATE FARM ON THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF EDUCATION.
IF MEMBER POSITION WAS
ESTABLISHED STUDENTS TO HAVE A
VOICE IN EDUCATION. A WAY FOR
YOU TO BE HEARD THE STATE LEVEL
. HELLO I CAN EUROPEAN BUDGET
THIS NUMBER CURRENT. CATHOLIC
WITH THAT THE SIX THREE STUDENTS
THINK HOW. AND FROM ONE
DISPOSITION BUT I WISH TO
POPULAR NOW. IT IS TRULY HIGH TO
REPRESENT THIS YEAR ABOUT IT.
WITH NO FOR STRUCTURE OF TO BE
TO HEAR THE NEED OF STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA THIS CAN LEAD TO THE
OF THE- OF. IN OUR STATE
ESPECIALLY UNDER REPRESENTED.
ONE IN THE PAST MOST. FOR
MEMBERS BEEN FOR MARCH URBAN AIR
LIKE THE BAY. OR LOS ANGELES.
THIS IS FROM LIKE THE CENTRAL
HOW NOT BEEN REPRESENT BUT YOU
CAN VIEW THEIR- OF WHAT PMR
NUMBER SHE BUT THE STATE BUDGET. LAST YEAR WHEN I WAS FOR THE
BERMAN THIS ALONG. ELEVEN OTHER
THE MICRO. WE YOU KNOW. AGREED
OTHER NUMBER THREE. IF THE
FRENCH. AFTER A- MOST SCHOOL
DIST PUBLIC STUDENTS NUMBER IN
ADVICE WE HELP. IT WOULD ONLY
SENSE OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WHICH MAKES THIS A
FOR MILLIONS OF. WOULD HAVE AS
WELL. AS A RESULT THE TO DIVIDE
COMMISSION. IN THIS BILL WILL
BECOME OF FROM REGIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. TO ALLOW
FOR ABILITY. AND A STRUCTURE
THAT WE HOPE WILL LAST MANY
YEARS. THE FIRST ACT BETTER
INFORMED STATE YOU CAN PART
NUMBER AT THE WE RELATED I.
THINK PART OF EDUCATION MEETING
. THANK YOU PAN FOR A CAR MUSIC
YOU THAT THE FOR OF THE COMP.
AND UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
YOUR VOICE EDUCATE. DECISION I
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE THOUGH ON
A WE HONOR. THANK YOU MISS YOU-
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN BEGIN. THE
MORNING ASKING OF THE SENECA
THAT ORGANIZING COMMITTEE.
FINING NEARLY A CAR SENIOR
ACTUAL MARSHALL HIGH IN THE
ANGELES. I'M HERE AT THE STATE
OF THE CAL COULD BE CHEN YOU CAN
COUNSEL BURDEN AT. THANK YOU
DEMONSTRATE. OR OR I MEAN I
DON'T. I YOU DID AND YOU GREW UP
IN THE LARGER COLD IN CALIFORNIA
AND THIS LARGE IN THE MAKE. I
DON'T KNOW HELP HAD ONE. THIRTY
SEVEN DISTRICTS. I'M SURE YOU
CAN MY- WHEN I FOR HEARD ABOUT
DISTRICT COURT AND A HALF YEARS
AGO I HAD A JOB. CONFERENCE
WHILE THE STATE. I'LL DIDN'T
KNOW THAT YOU CAN BE THIS IS
MAKERS RUNNING. EIGHT ON. AND
THAT IS YOU'RE ON A THE STREET
LEVEL.
HOW CAN A FEW DIFFERENT SAN
DIEGO PROPERLY REPRESENT AND
FORTY DOT THREE DIFFERENT
TROUBLED THAT. THE STATE. EVERY
STUDENT AT EVERY VOICE. KEEPING
EVERYTHING ON. EVERY STUDENT IN
EVERY REGION DESERVES TO BE
HEARD ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL AND
OUT OF THE UNITED. ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH DONE BY UCLA THERE ARE
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND. STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
LOOKING AT. IT AND MAKE UP 70%
OF THE POPULATION BOB BLACK
DIDN'T MAKE A 9% A STARK
CONTRAST IN COMPARISON TO
DIFFERENT MOMENT. ANOTHER STUDY
DONE BY UCLA'S THAT 10% OF
STUDENTS PUBLICLY IDENTIFY ON
THE PART OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. BY IMPLEMENTING A THIRTY
PERSON AT TO NOT ONLY WILL THE
YOUR GETTING FROM MORE REDUCE
REFERENCE DIRECT ON A STATE
LEVEL. STUDENTS THE STUDENTS
MEMBER BUT ALSO SHOW OUR THAT
THEIR VOICE. AND THAT THEREFORE
ARE BECAUSE CHANGE HE MAKES ALL
OF THE PLEASE A PLACE THAT THE
LOOK GOING EVERYDAY. THANK FOR
YOUR TIME AND. THANK YOU MISLI.
OKAY AT THIS POINT TIME WE ARE
GOING TO. SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THE- YEAH THAT- WHICH TO. I
DON'T SEE ANY OF THEIR- THANK
YOU DOUBLE ON WITH WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE THE TO ORVIS
MODERATOR WHICH PLEASE PROPPED
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH EIGHT.
WE'LL BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER
CARE- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TELL.
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE ZERO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY THE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FILED BY THE ZERO AT T. OPERATOR
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE SIMPLY SIT BACK INTO THE
CALL. IN ONE ZERO TO TEST
SUPPORT SB. NINE ZERO EIGHT. MR
SURE NOBODY'S GIVING UP THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR- SO
WITH THAT WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION NOT EXPECTING TO HEAR
ANY THERE EITHER BUT- PLEASE
PROCEED MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MUCH- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
OH EIGHT. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. OKAY
NOBODY AND NOBODY ABOVE WISHING
TO TESTIFY OKAY- WELL THANKS TO
ALL OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION WHAT
WITNESSES I WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. CENTER ARCHULETA. YOUR
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR- SENATOR
MY QUESTION IS IF THESE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH AB- PICKED
FROM WITHIN THEIR SCHOOL THE
REGION WE AS LEGISLATORS WOULD
BE ABLE TO RECOMMEND THEM WHAT
WOULD BE THE PROCESS TO BRING
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN IN TO
SACRAMENTO FOR THEIR VISITS. YES
THANK YOU CENTER OUTLET FOR YOUR
QUESTION- THE SELECTION PROCESS
MODELED AFTER THE SELECTION OF
THE STUDENT. THE STATE STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER SO- FOR THIS
COMMISSION STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS
AT EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT. SO YOU
YOU NEED TO NEED TO BE A STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER AT EITHER YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. BE CONTACTED
ENCOURAGED TO APPLY- THROUGH THE
STATE BOARD EDUCATION WEBSITE-
THERE RECEIVED THERE'S A
SCREENING COMMITTEE THAT WILL
ALSO INCLUDE THE STATE'S STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER. WHO THEN
IDENTIFIED THERE'S GOING TO
VERIFY SENSUALLY ONE MEMBER FOR
EACH REGION SO THAT'S HOW YOU
HAS THE TWELVE REGIONS. THE ONE
PERSON FOR EACH REGION PLUS THE
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER THEMSELVES
SO THAT WARMS THE COMMISSION
THIRTEEN- BUT THAT'S THE UPS
THAT WOULD BE THE SELECTION
PROCESS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. FINANCE
CENTER PAN SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A
POOR WE CAN'T- VOTE ON THAT NOW.
BUT THIS BILL- WILL BE BROUGHT
UP AND- I'VE AT VOTED ON THIS IS
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER PAN I
DO WANT TO MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
BECAUSE I SAW MR CALLOW WHEN I.
CAME IN. THIS MORNING AND
THEY'RE HERE- TO- WHAT THE MARIO
BLADE IT WILL- BUILDING WHICH IS
ON THE CONSENT ITEM AND I KNOW
YOU'RE HERE TO A SUPPORT THAT
BUT UNTIL WE- IT TOO WE HAVE A-
A QUORUM WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
HEAR THAT SO I JUST KIND OF
WANTED TO KEEP YOU APPRISED OF
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND CENTER PAN YOU'VE
GOT ANOTHER BILL BE FORCED
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. FOR
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
WHICH WILL ALLOW THE NEW AND
UPCOMING EVENTS CENTER IN
SACRAMENTO KNOWN AS THE CAP
RADIO LIFE TO QUALIFY FOR LONG
TERM ALCOHOL LICENSE. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL. PASSED FORTY YEARS CP
RADIO DELIVERED CRITICAL NEWS
HAS EXPANDED OUR WORLD THROUGH
THEIR STORIES ON ART AND LET
LAST YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED. FOR THE-
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE ARTS
INVESTED IN CAPITA LIFE. AND YOU
PERFORMANCE ENGAGEMENTS THAT
SPACE. THIS NEW VENUE WOULD
OFFER INCLUSIVE ENGAGING
ACCESSIBLE AND RELEVANT EVENT
EXPERIENCES FOR LOW TO NO COST.
HOWEVER CAP RADIO CURRENTLY DOES
NOT FALL WITHIN ONE OF THE ABC'S
ALCOHOL LICENSE TYPES AND WOULD
BE UNABLE TO DEPEND ON A
CRITICAL CRITICAL REVENUE
STREAM. THAT WILL ENSURE HIGH
QUALITY EVENTS AT AFFORDABLE
PRICE. THEREFORE SB THIRTY
SEVENTY SPECIFIED THAT A
NONPROFIT RADIO BROADCASTING
COMPANY WILL BE ADDED TO THE
VENUE OPTIONS THAT CAN SELL. AND
SERVE ALCOHOL BEVERAGES TWO
HOURS PRIOR TO IN ONE HOUR AFTER
THE PROGRAM. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- YOU'VE- YOU'VE IT MAY BE
IN SIGHT THE SENATE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING APPROPRIATE BEVERAGES TO
CELEBRATE IMPORTANT EVENTS.
AGAIN WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS CORNELIA BURKE WHO'S
REPRESENTING CAP RADIO AND WE
ALSO OF CORY DAY ON THE LINE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
I THINK THAT'S A COMPLIMENT. IT
IS. VERY MUCH SO. VERY GOOD WITH
THAT- MR BURKE- YOU WANT TO GET
STARTED SIR WELCOME. MORNING
CHAIR DONNA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CORNELIUS BURKE- I'M
HERE IN MY ROLE AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR CAPITAL PUBLIC RADIO
ON BEHALF OF OUR GM JUNE RAIN ON
OUR BOARD WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY IN A CAP RADIO IS THE
NPR AFFILIATE FOR THE SACRAMENTO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION. OUR
NEW COMMITTEE SPACE AND
COMMUNITY STUDIO- WILL BE A
BEACON FOR PUBLIC AFFAIRS
PROGRAMMING MUSIC ARTS- CIVIC
DISCOURSE AND THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW US TO HAVE THE REGULATORY
RELIEF TO GET A BC LICENSE- SO
WE CONTINUE OUR MISSION OF
PROVIDING NONPARTISAN. NOT FOR
PROFIT NEWS AND INFORMATION FOR
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE THANK YOU
SO MORE SO MUCH- FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU DR
PANTHER LEADERSHIP AND WE REALLY
URGENT I VOTE AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANKS MISTER BURKE WE'RE
GONNA. MOVED OUT TO COURT DAY ON
THE CO. MR BURKE YOU'RE FREE TO
BEGIN. I THINK IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT ASSISTANCE INSPECTIONS
. THE MODERATOR IS MR BURKE ON.
THE LIGHTING HI I AM WHAT I'LL
LOOK BRIDGE LINE HERE.
I DON'T SEE A LINE ON THE PHONE
LINE. OKAY- WHEN WE SEE HIM
WE'LL GET HIM TO BE ABLE TO-
TESTIFIES BUT. USE THAT YEAH YES
OKAY MY UNDERSTANDING HE'S UP
HERE AS ITS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THE BILL IN ANYBODY'S GOT
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR
THAT- MODERATOR LET'S OPEN THE
LINES FOR THOSE IN STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS HE
STATED IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED. BY ZERO FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY IN SUPPORT BY
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROUGHLY ON BEHALF OF THE
AFFECT AMOUNTS FOR IT SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY. HI MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NOW WILL DO THE SAME
THING WITH- THE OPPOSITION
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITED TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
NOW WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS ANYBODY IN CHAMBERS-
WISHING TO TESTIFY OR NOT
TESTIFY SKEWS ME JUST COMMENT ON
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY- WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT NOW SENATOR
SO WHAT. WE'LL REMEMBER THAT- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD I CENTER PAN WE
WILL TAKE THIS UP AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH LOOKING FOR TO
A CELEBRATION.
WELL NOW MOVES TO THE ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE ELEVEN
BY CENTER GLAZER. CENTER GLAZER
YOU MAY BEGIN OR YOU WANT TO GO
BACK FIVE. EITHER WAY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL SENATE BILL NINE ONE ONE.
IT'S A VERY APT NUMBER BECAUSE
SB NINE ONE ONE RESPONSE TO AN
EMERGENCY A REAL EMERGENCY AND
EMERGENCY IS THE THREAT POSED TO
OUR DEMOCRACY BY MISINFORMATION
. A FEW SMART WRITERS HAVE SAID
OUR FREE SPEECH AND OUR
DEMOCRACY ARE BEING OVERWHELMED
BY. CHEAP SPEECH. WE'VE ALWAYS
HAD LIARS AND FRAUDSTERS WHO
HAVE SOUGHT TO MISINFORM AND USE
MISINFORMATION TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT IN THE INTERNET
AGE ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND
TWO METHODS OF SPREADING
MISINFORMATION HAVE BECOME SO
CHEAP. THAT ANYONE CAN DO IT.
GOOD OLD FASHIONED FACT BASED
NEWS MEANWHILE IS NOT CHEAP.
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS HAVE TO HIRE
REPORTERS AND EDITORS AND NOW
WEB DESIGNERS AND THEY HAVE TO
SELL ADVERTISING AND
SUBSCRIPTIONS TO SUPPORT THOSE
COSTS. THE RESULT UNFORTUNATELY
IS THAT CHEAP SPEECH HAS BECOME
MORE WIDESPREAD THAN FREE SPEECH
. AND THE PURVEYORS OF
MISINFORMATION DON'T JUST SPREAD
LIES AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEY ALL THEY ALSO DELIBERATELY
UNDERMINE OUR INSTITUTIONS FROM
GOVERNMENT ACADEMIA TO THE
MEDIA. ALL IN AN EFFORT TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT NONE OF
THESE GROUPS CAN BE TRUSTED.
NATIONALLY MORE THAN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED NEWSPAPERS HAVE FAILED
ALMOST 25% OF THE NINE THOUSAND
NEWSPAPERS THAT WERE PUBLISHED
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HAD THEIR
OWN NEWSPAPER IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND NOW HAVE NO ORIGINAL
REPORTING WHATSOEVER IN PRINT OR
DIGITALLY HAS GROWN TO EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITIES. NEWS DESERT'S. IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S BEEN A 24%
DECLINE IN NEWSPAPERS FROM FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE TO THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS CIRCULATION HAS
DROPPED BY NEARLY HALF FROM
THIRTEEN MILLION TO SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION. THIS BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. SIX TO HELP CLOSE
THAT GAP. THAT THIS DECLINE HAS
CREATED A GAP THAT INCREASINGLY
IS FILLED BY MISINFORMATION. IT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THIS BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO LOCAL MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS AND JOURNALISTS TO
SUPPORT COVERAGE OF LOCAL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS THE GRANT TO BE DIRECTED
TO PLACES WERE CREDIBLE NEWS
COVERAGE IS SCARCE. AND TO
COMMUNITIES THAT TRADITIONAL
MEDIA HAVE LONG IGNORED. ONE
FOURTH OF THE GRANT MONEY WOULD
BE SET ASIDE FOR ETHNIC MEDIA.
AND ONE FOURTH FOR MEDIA SERVING
SMALL COMMUNITIES. AS SOME MIGHT
QUESTION WHETHER THIS IS A
PROPER ROLE FOR GOVERNMENT. BUT
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PROTECTING OUR DEMOCRACY. THIS
BILL IS MODELED AFTER FEDERAL
SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC TELEVISION
AND RADIO AND OUR OWN STATE
SUPPORT FOR THE ARTS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. SB NINE
ONE ONE WOULD CREATE A FIFTEEN
MEMBER BOARD WITH THE DIVERSE
BIPARTISAN MEMBERSHIP. TO
SOLICIT REVIEW AND APPROVE THE
GRASS THE BOARD WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM CONSIDERING
PARTISAN POLITICS IN ITS WAY
INTO GRANT APPLICATIONS. AND THE
BOARD COULD ALSO ACCEPT
DONATIONS FROM PRIVATE SOURCES.
INCLUDING NONPROFIT FOUNDATIONS
AND USE THIS MONEY TO SUPPORT
SUPPLEMENT IT'S PUBLIC MONEY.
MEMBERS JAMES MADISON THE AUTHOR
OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT CALLED
OUR FREE PRESS ONE OF THE GREAT
WALL WORKS OF LIBERTY. HE WAS
RIGHT BUT TRAGICALLY TRAGICALLY
THAT ALL WORK IS NOW CRUMBLING
AND AS IT DOES OUR DEMOCRACY IS
PUT IN PERIL WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BUTTRESS
BOTH AND THAT'S WHAT SB NINE ONE
ONE WOULD DO. BEFORE I CLOSED
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
ALL THE INPUT THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED FROM ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION YET THE
MEDIA SERVICES AND COMMON CAUSE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SOME OTHERS
I'LL CONTINUE I HOPE TO CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE OF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM SO WE
CAN REFINE THE BILL I EVEN MORE
THAN IT IS TODAY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- I.%
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER-
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE DERREN
MACHEL. AND JESSICA GONZALEZ WHO
ARE BOTH ON THE COASTLINE. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF MR
MICHELLE YOU MAY BEGIN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I AM THERE ON THE SHELF
PREIDENT AND CEO OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC MEDIA. I'M
ALSO THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC TELEVISION A
GROUP OF PUBLIC BROADCASTING
STATIONS IN THE STATE. THE CPT
IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT SENATOR
GLAZERS SB NINE ELEVEN ON BEHALF
OF OUR MEMBER STATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE. PUBLIC BROADCASTING
HAS LONG PRIDED ITSELF IN OUR
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE
FREE TRUST WORTHY EDUCATIONAL
AND INFORMATIVE PROGRAMMING
AVAILABLE TO OUR VIEWERS. ARE
PDF MODEL IS TRUSTED NONPARTISAN
CELEBRATES DEMOCRACY AND OFFERS
QUALITY DIALOGUE AND REPORTS ON
ISSUES OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS. PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW WHERE THEY CAN CONFIDENTLY
GO TO READ VIEW AND CONSUME FAIR
AND ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
FORMULATE EDUCATED POSITION THE
PUBLIC THING THE TOUCH THEIR
LIVES ON A DAILY BASIS. THAT'S
WHY THE CPT WAS SO EXCITED TO
SEE THE INTRODUCTION OF SENATOR
GLAZERS BILL IN RECENT YEARS
WE'VE SEEN A DECLINE IN SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE AND SPECIALLY ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR EXAMPLE THE
CREATION OF A BOARD TO FUND
PUBLIC INTEREST MEDIA WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL TV STATIONS
JOURNALIST. SMALL NEWSPAPERS AND
OTHERS TO WRITE AND PRODUCE
TRUSTED CONTENT THAT IS GROUNDED
IN COVERING THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. WE ALSO HOPE THAT THE
BILL WILL ENCOURAGE
COLLABORATION ACROSS MEDIA TYPES
FOR EXAMPLE HERE AT- OUR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC MEDIA
GROUP WE ENGAGE WITH SMALL
NEWSPAPERS ACROSS THE REGION TO
BOLSTER LOCAL NEWS OUTRAGE BUT
AS YOU MAY KNOW FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC BROADCASTING HAS NEVER
BEEN COMPLETELY ROBUST IN THIS
BILL COULD ENABLE US TO CONTINUE
THE GOOD WORK THAT STATIONS
LIKE. SAN DIEGO PDF IS
PERFORMING. WITH THEIR NIGHTLY
NEWS PROGRAM. OR STATION TO
CURRENTLY HAVE THIS OF
PROGRAMMING LONG AN INFORMATIVE
NEWS PROGRAM USING GRANT MONEY
AUTHORIZED BY THE BILL. CPT IS
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR GLAZER AND
HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH OUR
GROUP AND WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THAT'S THE NINE
ELEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER LOST.
LAWSHALL MISTER DOLLARS FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN DODD SENATOR GLAZERS
COMMITTEE MEMBER THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE ON THE COAST CEO
OF FREE PRESS ACTION EVERY
TRANSACTION WE ADVANCE
JOURNALISM POLICY TO SUPPORT A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY DEMOCRACY
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
NUMBERS IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
BASED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE EXTREMELY EXCITED FOR THE
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC MEDIA OVER
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE U. S.
HAS LOST OVER HALF THE NEWSPAPER
REPORTERS COVERING STATE AND
LOCAL BE. CALIFORNIA'S LAW 25%
OF THE NEWSPAPER AND TOTAL NEW
CIRCULATION OF DROPPED BY 50%
THE DEFAMATION OF LOCAL NEWS HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMS THE
POOR PEOPLE OF COLOR RURAL
COMMUNITY AND IMMIGRANT. FOR
MISSING LOCAL JOURNALISM THAT
HELPS US MAKE GOOD CHOICES ABOUT
EVERYTHING FROM HEALTH AND
SAFETY HOW TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND A MOM I STRUGGLE
TO FIND RELIABLE INFORMATION
WHEN MY KIDS RETURN TO SCHOOL
INDEPENDENT. THERE WAS ONLY ONE
SOURCE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ITSELF WITH THE SCHOOL BOARD
PRINCIPAL AND TEACHERS OFTEN
SHARING CONFLICTING INFORMATION.
THERE WAS NO INDEPENDENT
REPORTING ON WEATHER'S
SCHOOLROOMS WERE PROPERLY
VENTILATED WHERE TO DISTRICT
WHICH FOLLOWING STATE AND LOCAL
PROTOCOL. YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
RELY ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT ACTORS
WHETHER THOSE PEOPLE BOARD LAW
ENFORCEMENT AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT BOARD FOR CITY
COUNCIL AT OUR SCHOOL TOWARDS IN
THAT INFORMATION. AND IT'S
OBVIOUS THE CORPORATE MEDIA WILL
NOT BE BACK GOOD JOURNALISM
ISN'T THE ONLY PROFITABLE AND
EVEN IF LOCAL TV STATIONS AND
MAXWELL THEY CONTINUE TO LAY OFF
LOCAL REPORTERS. PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IS A GREAT WAY TO
CONFRONT THE COLLAPSE OF LOCAL
MEDIA AND THE RISE OF
DISINFORMATION THIS BILL COULD
NOT ONLY INVIGORATE THE CIVIC
LIFE OF CALIFORNIANS BUT ALSO
SERVE AS AN INNOVATIVE MODEL FOR
OTHERS EIGHT. IN PARTICULAR FREE
PRESS ACTION IN STRONG FAVOR OF
THE BILL CALLED AND SUPPORTING.
ETHNIC AND COMMUNITY JOURNALISM
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WITH THE
ON THE PROVISION. WERE EQUALLY
COMMITTED WORKING WITH GLAZER ON
STRENGTHENING FOR REPRESENTS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THE SIMPLE
THAT. THANK YOU THIS
CONSOLIDATES- WELL NOW TO. MOVED
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAIN WHO WON
TEST SOME. SEE NOBODY HERE LET'S
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
ELEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH- WHITE TWENTY FIVE MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING TIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MEDIA. ALLIANCE TO SAY THAT WITH
THE CURRENT FAX- AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT AND S. B. NINE ONE
ONE THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER
GO EIGHT EIGHT ONE ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
ONE ONE. NINE THIRTY YOUR OPEN.
HI THERE MY AUNT CHIU COBB
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE REALLY
PLEASED BY THE BILL AND EXCITED
TO BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHORED POPPING ON AND THEN
MANY. NOT QUITE YET BUT HOPING
SUPPORT AT THE. NINE ELEVEN YEAH
THANK YOU. AND MR SURE NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. SEEING NONE WELL NOW
MOVED ON TO WITNESSES WAITED TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. NINE ELEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE ELEVEN CLAYTON AT ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. GIVE YOURSELF
UP ONE BEARDED YOURSELF UP FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE ELEVEN.
AND NOBODY IS KILLING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR THANKS
TO ALL OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WE
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I SEE CENTER ARCHULETA. PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER ARCHULETA. I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND THANK YOU MR
LIKE TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR ON SB
NINE ELEVEN AND I'VE ASKED TO BE
A CO AUTHOR- THIS BILL TRULY
WILL HELP THE INDUSTRY WE CAN
ALL LOOK BACK YEARS UPON YEARS
FROM WHEN PERHAPS SOME OF US
WERE YOUNG CHILDREN AND WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY DELIVER OF THE
LOCAL NEWSPAPER IN EVERY
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE I GREW UP HAD A
LOCAL NEWSPAPER AND IF AS WE
HEARD- THE DEMISE OF ONE AFTER
THE OTHER AFTER THE OTHER. CHAU
OUR COMMUNITIES NEED THE SUPPORT
IN THIS BILL NINE ELEVEN WILL
BRING THAT BACK AND TO HELP
THESE LOCAL BUSINESSES AND THEY
ARE BUSINESSES TO INFORM US EACH
AND EVERY DAY- WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOT ONLY IN THE WORLD IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I'M HOPING THAT-
THE BOARD WILL- ACKNOWLEDGE THE
HARD WORK OF MEN AND WOMEN
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
DEVOTED THEIR LIVES TO
JOURNALISM AND- PUBLIC MEDIA SO
I HARDLY- I JUST- BUT CITED
ABOUT THE BILL. AND WHEN IT
COMES UP FOR VOTE I WILL VOTE
YEAH HI AND I HOPE EVERYONE ELSE
WILL TOO THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR NIELSEN. WELL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE. THE NOBLE
INTENT OF THIS. I SUPPORT AND I
UNDERSTAND I COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS BEING ATTENTIVE TO AN
ISSUE THERE'S BEEN LONG
DEVELOPING. I WATCHED OVER THE
YEARS FOR THE LOCAL HOMETOWN
PAPERS DIED. I WATCHED OVER THE
YEARS WERE. EVEN LARGE
NEWSPAPERS LIKE THE SANTA ROSA
PRESS DEMOCRAT. WHEN INDIVIDUAL
WORK CHOIR BY THE NEW YORK TIMES
I SAID LOCAL. INPUT IS DEAD. AND
THAT'S HAPPENED ALL OVER SO WE
DO HAVE A PROBLEM. BUT I AM
ALWAYS WARY. OF GIVING MORE
POWER TO GOVERNMENT. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE WE'RE GIVING
HUGE POWER THE GOVERNMENT.
GRANTS MONEY. THESE PAPERS WILL
BE DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT. AND
GOVERNMENT AS A SUBTLE AND NOT
SO SUBTLE WAYS OF IMPOSING ITS
WILL ON THOSE WHO ARE. DEPENDING
ON IT IN THIS CASE IT WILL BE BE
DEPENDING. I BELIEVE THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO SAVE OUR HOMETOWN
NEWSPAPERS I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT VESTING TOO MUCH
AUTHORITY. AND POWER FISCAL
SO I WILL BE A NOBLE. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR BORCHERS. THIS IS A AREA THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE ITEMS THAT- DOES INDEED
CAPTURE IMAGINATION- YOU KNOW
I'VE HAD- DISCUSSIONS- FORMALLY
AND INFORMALLY ABOUT THE DEMISE
OF- SMALL PAPERS AND SMALL
OUTLETS- JUST BY WAY OF
REFERENCE- WHEN I FIRST EMERGED
ON THE POLITICAL SCENE. IN MY
NECK OF THE WOODS THE FRESNO BEE
WAS THE DOMINANT NEWS OUTLET.
NOTHING HAPPENS WITHOUT IT BEING
COVERED EVERYTHING WAS COVERED
AND THEY HAD A SIGN REPORTERS-
IN EVERY CONCEIVABLE AREA. AND
AT THIS POINT- UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S GONE THROUGH THE TRANSITION
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE HAS WHERE
IT REALIZE IT HAS RELIED A LOT
ON ASSOCIATED PRESS OR WITHIN
THE MCCLATCHY FAMILY OF MATERIAL
THAT IS THAT IS PRODUCED. AND SO
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE DEMISE OF
LOCAL CONTENT OUR LOCAL INSIGHT
ARE WHICH I THINK YOU KNOW-
UNDERGIRDS- YOU KNOW. THE TYPE
REPORTING THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY- WITHOUT
WITH WITHOUT GOING TO ANY MORE
DETAIL WE KNOW SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE. AS I LOOK AT THE
BILL HERE IT I ALMOST WANT TO.
JUST THROW OUT AN IDEA FOR A
FRIENDLY. AMENDMENT FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER ALONG THE WAY. BECAUSE
THE ISSUE IS NOT JUST LOCAL
CONTACT. IT'S ALSO ETHICAL
REPORTING. MOVING INTO THE REALM
OF WHAT THE OLD COLUMBIA SCHOOL
OF JOURNALISM WHICH WOULD PUT
OUT AS THE TENETS OF ETHICAL
JOURNALISM DISPASSIONATE
REPORTING. DOUBLE SOURCING.
EDITOR IN PEER REVIEW OF CONTENT
. ARE IN THE IN THERE'S ABOUT
FOUR FIVE OTHERS THAT GO INTO
THIS I THINK TO MAKE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WORK IT'S ALMOST AS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT THIS
COMMISSIONER THIS BODY. TO PUT
FORWARD IN IN THE CALIFORNIA
MARKET PLACE THE NEWS MARKET
PLACE. WHAT THE STANDARDS ARE
BECAUSE EVERY TOM DICK AND HARRY
ON INSTAGRAM OR FACEBOOK NOW
PUTS THEMSELVES OUT AS HAVING A
PRESS CREDENTIAL BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE LACK OF RESPECT THAT
FOLKS HAVE- ALLOWED FOR THOSE
WHO WERE APPROPRIATELY SKILLED
OR EDUCATED. OR EXPERIENCE IN
CERTAIN DISCIPLINES- THAT THEIR
OPINION. IS ON PAR WITH SOMEONE
WHO HAS NO BACKGROUND IN THAT-RESPECTIVE AREA THIS DRIVES ME
MAD. SO HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
THIS IT'S NOT JUST PUTTING MONEY
INTO LOCAL CONTENT IT'S TURNING
. IT'S A GREAT RING TOWN BY THE
WAY THE TICKET IN THE. IT IS
MISSION IMPOSSIBLE. THAT'S WHAT
YOUR COMMENTS PROVOKED CENTER
EXACTLY. BUT LISTEN I KNOW
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THIS AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL I'VE BEEN
CERTAINLY AT THE INTERNATIONAL
LEVEL IN ITS GONE VIRTUALLY
NOWHERE BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE MICROCOSM CALIFORNIA YOU NOW
ARE IN A POSITION THROUGH THIS
BILL OR SOME VARIATION OF IT AS
IT EVOLVES TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING TRULY SIGNIFICANT. CAN
I ASK THE AUTHOR THROUGH THE
CHAIR IF I MAY. WOULD USE WOULD
YOU CONSIDER INCORPORATING. A
RULES AND IN STANDARDS AND
CERTIFICATION. ROSS SAYS
COMPONENT TO A BILL LIKE THIS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS WHAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE- CALIFORNIA
REPORTING ESPECIALLY LOCAL. THE
CHAIR IF I MAY PLEASE WELL I
CERTAINLY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS FROM THE
SENATOR FRESNO. AND I'M IN
AGREEMENT NOW- I DON'T RECALL
WHETHER WE'VE WRITTEN IT INTO
THE BILL ITSELF BUT I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO AN AMENDMENT
THAT. MAKES IT CLEAR THAT- THAT
THERE IS A- IT THERE IS THERE
ARE JOURNALISTS NATIONAL
JOURNALISTIC STANDARDS THAT ARE
IN PLACE TODAY- THAT- AS WE I
ASK PEOPLE TO ABIDE BY ETHICAL-
ENCOUNTERS IN OUR ELECTIONS.
THERE IS A SIMILAR STANDARDS
THAT HAVE BEEN SET AND I I'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
INCORPORATE THOSE ARE DIRECT THE
BOARD MEMBER. WE'RE NOT THE ONES
WHO ARE MAKING THESE DECISIONS
THIS BILL SET UP A BOARD AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS BUT WE COULD CERTAINLY
I CREATE A STANDARD PERHAPS THE
EXISTING NATIONAL STANDARD ON
JOURNALISTIC AND YOU KNOW
INTEGRITY. I SOMEHOW- AN
OBLIGATION FOR THEM TO FOLLOW
BUT THAT'S WORK ON THAT AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
SENTIMENT THAT YOU'RE EXPRESSING. THAT AND BE THE SAME THING
THAT I WOULD WANT TO ACHIEVE.
BECAUSE BY THAT. WELCOME TO HELP
HERE IF I MAY UM. THIS IS THAT
RARE OPPORTUNITY I THINK A BILL
LIKE THIS. IS JUST HALF WAY
THERE AND I RESPECT ENORMOUSLY
THE AUTHOR- THE WORK YOU YOU DO
AND NOT JUST THE SOME OF THE
OTHERS. THIS REALLY NEEDS TO
HAVE. THAT COMPONENT- THE END
THROUGH A BOARD. OF THIS SORT
THAT WOULD BE THE VENUE FOR THE
CREATION OF THIS TYPE OF
RIGOROUS SCRUTINY AS-
CREDENTIALING AUTHORITY. THANK
YOU- CENTER CALM UNDER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I- WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- BRINGING
THIS BILL. FORWARD ALTHOUGH THE
BILL NUMBER KIND OF ALWAYS GIVES
ME A LITTLE PAUSE- I WANT TO
JUST EXPRESS THAT I AM LIKE THIS
BILL AND I APPLAUD ITS GOAL TO
REALLY SUPPORT CALIFORNIA LOCAL
SMALL AND ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS-
I ALSO FEEL COMPELLED TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO INDEPENDENT
JOURNALISM IN THE LOCAL PAPERS
WE KNOW THAT I BELIEVE THAT
JOURNALISTS ARE EAST CENTRAL
WORKERS AND THEY ARE UNDER
ATTACK AS IS THE TRUTH AND WE
SHOULD ALWAYS BE WORKING TO
PROTECT FREE PRESS FREE SPEECH
AND OUR JOURNALISTS WHO ARE
DOING THE HARD WORK OF TRYING TO
GIVE US INFORMATION. I HAVE TO
EITHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO POSE TO THE
CHAIR. JUST FOR CONSIDERATION
FOR THIS AUTHOR AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND I KNOW THEY DO
NOT DIRECTLY RELATE TO THE BILL
BUT THE MAIN ALLOW FOR SOME
DISCUSSION AND INCORPORATION IN
THE IN THE IN THE IN THE PANEL
AND THE ADVISORY- PANEL THAT'S-
A PROPOSED TO BE FORMED. SO THE
FIRST IS THERE A WAY TO INCLUDE
OR TO CONSIDER- FOUR TWO MAYBE
CLARIFY. THAT THE LOCAL PAPERS.
ARE INDEED LOCAL AND COMMUNITY
OUTLETS BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT-
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE. THE
LOCAL PRESS OR THE COMMUNITY
PAPER IS NOT REALLY FROM THE
COMMUNITY SO MAYBE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO ARTICULATE
THAT ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A GRANT COMPONENT
AND WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE GRANT DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO LOCAL COMMUNITY PAPERS
OR MEDIA OUTLETS THAT ARE
SHARING LOCAL NEWS SO THAT WAS
JUST ONE THOUGHT AND THEN I KNOW
THIS HAS BEEN AN ISSUE IN THE
PAST AND THIS BILL. IS NOT
DEALING WITH THE SECOND ISSUE
THAT I'M GOING TO BRING UP. BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT CITIES ARE
REQUIRED. BY LAW TO PAY TO POST
IN PUBLIC NEWSPAPERS. AND WE
KNOW THAT. THAT PAYMENTS- IS
REALLY IS TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL
FOR OUR LOCAL PRINT NEWSPAPERS
THAT ARE OFTENTIMES STRUGGLING
TO STAY IN BUSINESS. AND THEN WE
ALSO KNOW HAT THERE ARE ONLINE
OUTLETS AS WELL. AND THE LAW
DOES SAY PRINT NEWSPAPERS BUT IS
THERE MAY BE ALSO WAY IN SORT OF
HOW THIS CONTINUES TO GET FRAMED
AN ARTICULATE TO MAYBE CONSIDER
ALLOWING FOR THOSE PAPERS FOR
THOSE MDIA OUTLETS THAT HAVE
BOTH A PRINT AND ONLINE-
PRESENCE. THEN MAYBE ALLOW FOR
SOME OF THE POSTING TO HAPPEN
AND I ONLY SHARE THAT BECAUSE I
HAVE A DISTRICT THAT IS
INCREDIBLY INTERESTED IN LOCAL
JOURNALISM. AND EVERY TIME
THERE'S A BILL THAT COMES UP
THAT'S ON THIS ISSUE. I GET TONS
OF CALLS AND SO I'VE BEEN-
TRAINED TO GO TO FOLKS WHEN I
GET A BILL. OF THIS NATURE AND
SO I DID. AND I'M I'M ACTUALLY
SHARING TWO QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
COME FROM THE DISTRICT- I THINK
HOPING FOR FEEDBACK OR FROM SOME
SORT OF ENGAGEMENT FROM- THE
LEGISLATURE N. TAG YOU'RE IT
BECAUSE- THIS IS THE ONLY BILL
SO FAR I'VE SEEN THAT DEALS WITH
LOCAL PAPER SO. JUST TO THE
CHAIR I HAVE THOSE TWO- COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS- FOR THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER. THANK YOU CENTER
COMMERCENTRE GLAZER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND AYE I WOULD
INDEED I THANK I THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER FOR LOS ANGELES FOR.
HEARING THOSE OBSERVATIONS AND I
CAN TELL THAT YOU HAVE THAT SAME
GREAT HEART THAT I HAVE FOR.
GREAT LOCAL JOURNALISM AND HOW
IMPORTANT AND IMPACTFUL IT IS
BEEN IN THE STRUGGLES THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH AS-
THERE'S TRANSITIONS IN THAT
WORLD WITH THAT WITH DIGITAL
ONLINE. AS AS SHE SPEAKS UP- I
AM OPEN TO TRYING O FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT LOCAL
CERTIFICATION THAT THEY ARE
LOCAL AND I'M OPEN TO ANY IDEAS
THERE TO TRY TO. MANEUVER
THROUGH THAT DIVERSITY OF MEDIA
THAT WE DO HAVE LOCALLY OUT
THERE- TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
THAT BOARD SO THAT WHEN THEY
THEY'VE- WE'VE AS YOU KNOW IN
THIS BILL WE'VE CREATED SOME
EXTRAORDINARY SET ASIDE SO THAT.
THAT THEY'RE THEY THEY THEY MEET
THAT PURPOSE AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD WANT TO SEE THERE AS WELL-
IN REGARD TO THE BROADER KIND-
POINT OF- AT THE THAT POSTING.
MANDATES CAN IS NOT A DIRECT
ISSUE HERE- I SHARE HER- HER OUR
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT- AS
THAT THE MEDIA HAS MODERNIZE
THAT WE ALSO MODERNIZE OUR-
RULES AND REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS
OF POSTING BUT- I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS EXACTLY THAT VEHICLE.
DATA AYE AYES AYE WE BOTH COMMIT
THE SAME PLACES THAT WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT LOCAL JOURNALISM OR ELSE
IT'S GOING TO DIE. AND OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE DEPENDENT UPON
IT OUR DEMOCRACIES DEPEND UPON
IT SO WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
AND I. LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU BUT-
BEFORE YOU SPEAK CENTER WHO BOB
BECKER. I RETHOUGHT- THERE WAS
SOMEBODY UP IN THE GALLERY THAT
WANTED TO SPEAK- AS A TWEEN AREA
AND I SAID NO BUT- YOU KNOW. THE
SIZE OF THIS ROOM KIND OF
DICTATES OF WE'VE BEEN A SMALL
ARC. COMMITTEE ROOM I WOULD
HAVE. SEEN THAT HAPPEN INTEL I
KNOW IT'S NOT CUSTOMARY. I'M
GONNA GO BACK UPSTAIRS ALLOW.
SOMEBODY FROM THE PUBLIC TO TALK
PLEASE PROCEED APOLOGIZE. GOOD
MORNING. A SENATOR YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP MY NAME
IS FOR A BAR SAUDI I AM THE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY PUBLICATIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR ETHNIC MEDIA PARTNERS TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL
FOR THE SENATOR WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR HIS WORK IN THIS AREA. AND
TO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATIONS AND HEARING
HIS FEEDBACK ON THE AMENDMENTS
WE'VE PROVIDED SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
. SENATOR BACKER ORDERS JUST
QUICKLY- I THINK THE AUTHOR
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BUILT ON REPRESENTS A LOT OF
SMALL COMMUNITIES AT TWENTY FIVE
SMALL CITIES WE SEE THE NEED FOR
THIS THERE HAS BEEN A RISE IN
NONPROFIT MEDIA WHICH HAS BEEN
POSITIVE- BUT I STILL THINK THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED I LIKE THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED BASED ON SOME
ESTABLISH PRECEDENTS THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE POINTED OUT BY THE
AUTHOR- WITH PUBLIC TELEVISION
ND OTHER- INSTANCES OF THAT SO
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
THANK CENTER BACK OR ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING. SPEAKING IN THE
CHAMBERS HERE SAYING NONE WE'RE
GONNA PAUSE BEFORE YOU- CLOSE
SENATOR GLAZERS- THE SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SURE DODD HERE START HERE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARTILLERY HERE BAKER
BAKER HERE FOR JUST. BURGE'S
PRESENT BRADFORD GLAZER PRESENT
GLAZER PRESENT WESSEL WEST OF
HERE JONES JONES HERE KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HERE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
HERE PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK. WELL
THIS YEAR WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SECRETARY- CONSIDERED
A CLOSE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS FROM
THAT FROM ALL OF MY FRIENDS FROM
THE NORTH FROM MY FRIEND FROM
NOT FRESNO OF. LOS ANGELES FROM
. THE PENINSULA- I TELL YOU
SOMETHING WE ALL SEE YOU KNOW
THIS IS A SLOW MOTION CRASH WERE
ALL WATCHING IT OKAY WE SEE IT-
IN FRONT OF US WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT IS TO A
THRIVING DEMOCRACY WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S A CRUCIAL ELEMENT AND OUT
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY IT TO
SHORE UP THAT FOUNDATION. THIS
NOTHING'S PERFECT THIS BILL MAY
NOT BE PERFECT BUT WE'RE OPEN TO
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO MAKE IT
BETTER- WE HAVE PURPOSELY
CREATED A MODEL THAT DOES NOT
HAVE GOVERNMENT DICTATING WHO
GETS WHAT IF THE BUDGET WAS TO
ALLOW FUNDS TO FLOW THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE SET UP TO BE APPOINTED
BY PARTISAN DIVERSE- ETCETERA
AND SO THE IDEA THAT THAT
GOVERNMENT'S GOING TO BE
CONTROLLING THE MEDIA I THINK IS
A FALSE ONE IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN UNDER THE BILL THIS AS
BEFORE YOU TODAY- BUT IT'S NOT A
PERFECT MODEL BUT IT IS A MODEL
THAT HAS WORKED. IN THE COUNTRY
AND IT'S A MODEL THAT EVEN HAS
WORKED HERE IN OUR STATE. WITH
THE ARTS COUNCIL WE'RE NOT
DECIDING WHETHER I LIKE THAT
PICTURE I LIKE THAT SCULPTURE.
WE DECIDE TO SET ASIDE SOME
MONEY NOT VERY MUCH BUT SOME.
AND ABOARD MAKES THOSE CHOICES
THOUGHTFUL CHOICES UNDER
GUIDELINES AND STANDARDS IN
UNDER REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THIS BILL PROVIDES A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET. REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
BACK SO WE CAN SEE HOW THEY'VE
MADE THEIR THOUGHTFUL DECISIONS.
AND WE CAN DECIDE TO CONTINUE
WITH. OR TO END IT. THOSE
CHOICES REMAIN OURS. BUT THE
EDITORIAL INDEPENDENCE. IS BUILT
INTO THIS BILL IT'S BUILT INTO
THIS BILL. WITH DIVERSITY.
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE AND WE
KNOW. THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IS NOT SO SMALL
MATTER NOT ABOUT A DISTRICT
ISSUE HERE THERE THIS IS ABOUT
THE FUNDAMENTALS OF WHO AND WHAT
BRINGS US TOGETHER AND THAT'S
OUR DEMOCRACY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER THE
MOTION DON'T WE HAVE A MOTION. I
DON'T HAVE A MOTION HERE YET.
I'M GONNA GO WITH THAT- CENTER
CALMER HAD A HAND UP FIRST- SO
WITH THE MATT MOTION IS TO PASS
FOR. YOU APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE SB NINE
ELEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS DOT. HI START BY
NIELSEN NIELSEN NIELSEN NO ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI BAKER.
BAKER HI GORGEOUS. BRADFORD
GLAZER GLAZER HI WESO GLAZER AYE
JONES. JONES NO KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK. WELCOME
NO. THAT'S SIXTY FOUR CHAIRMAN
ON CALL SIX TO FOR THAT ITEM IS
ON CALL WE'RE GONNA MOVED OUT
TO- THE CONSENT ITEMS- CAN I
HAVE A MOTION FOR WELL LET ME
JUST BEGIN BY- THE CONSECUTIVE
HONORED IT INCLUDES FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. TEN ELEVEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. SB
ELEVEN NINETY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE SIXTEEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE TWELVE
FIFTY THREE AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN S. C. R. SEVENTY AND
SINCE WE I KNOW WE HAVE PEOPLE.
IN THE- CHAMBERS TODAY THAT'S
FOR THE MARIO A BLADE OF
BUILDING. SO WITH THAT- DO YOU
HAVE A MOTION CENTER WILK IS
MOVED- SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY-
CENTER WILL MEMBERS REMINDER
PLEASE WAIT UNTIL YOUR MIKE IS
TURNED ON PLEASE SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO MIKE- PLEASE SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. DODD I THOUGHT I'D
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA BARTOLOTTA I'D BETTER
. BORDERS BORDERS I BRADFORD
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE WESSEL. WESEL
II JONES. JONES I KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK WILL DIE WILK AYE.
THAT'S NINE SHERMAN ON CALL.
THIS DIED VOTES THAT BILL IS ON
CALL NOW WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE FIRST A COUPLE OF THE ITEMS
- BY DOCTOR P. AND FIRST ONE IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE OH
EIGHT- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER ARCHULETA MOVES- FACTORY
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. OUR DEPOSIT AMENDED YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SB NINE OH A MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD AYE DODD AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HI BAKER OR
JUST BORDERS NO BRADFORD GLAZER
PLEASE R. I. WESO WHAT'S SO I'D
JONES. JONES NO KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK. WILK HI. FIVE TO
FOUR GERMAN ON CALL. THE BILL IS
ON CALL WILL NOW MOVE TO FIND
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO THAT'S
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY ALSO BY
SENATOR PAN I WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THAT. SENATOR GLAZERS MOVES-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
SO DON'T. THE BEST
APPROPRIATIONS. COMMITTEE ASKED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THANKS AGAIN
OF ALL OVER THE PLACE HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH THE VOTE
OKAY THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SB
THIRTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD. AYE DODD
AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARE JULY AYE BAKER
BAKER HI GORGEOUS. BORDERS AYE
BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER AYE
WESSEL WETZEL I JONES. KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK THE GUY WHAT HI.
JONES I GERMAN THAT'S GOT ONE.
THAT'S TEN ENCORE. BEST TEN DOES
THAT BILL IS ON CALL WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM OR S. B. TEN
TEN BY CENTER SKINNER. CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY BEGIN THANKS O
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
SB TEN TEN. PUTS THE STATE. WILL
IN EFFECT RJ PUTS THE STATE'S
MONEY WORDS ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
IT. REQUIRES OUR OWN.
DEPARTMENTS DGS FOR OUR STATE
OWNED VEHICLES THE FLEETS TO
MOVE QUICKER TWO ZERO MISSION
VIA. AS I THINK MOST OF YOU KNOW
WE HAVE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
THE GOVERNOR THAT INDICATES WE
WILL NOT BE SELLING- ALSO FUEL
POWERED VEHICLES- WITHIN A
CERTAIN DATE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE HELPING THE
TRANSFORMATION THE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION. FOR OUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND THE MORE
PURCHASING UP THOSE VEHICLES
THEN IT HELPS TO BRING THE PRICE
DOWN IT HELPS TO STIMULATE MORE
MODELS. AND IT IS OBVIOUSLY
BENEFICIAL FOR US FROM BOTH THE
CLIMATE PROTECTION POINT OF VIEW
AND AN AIR QUALITY POINT OF VIEW
SO WHAT SB TEN TEN DOES. IS IT
HAS THE STATE'S ZERO EMISSION
PURCHASING REQUIREMENTS IT MOVES
THAT TO A 100% ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX FOR
LIGHT DUTY AND A 100% ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY. AND I'D LIKE MY
EXPERT. WITNESSES TO REPRESENT
BILL MCGOVERN FROM THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR AND READ OUT A
STRING CAL START. OKAY THANK YOU
US SENATOR- MR- WE GATHER. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TODD- MEMBERS I'M
BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN TEN. TRANSPORTATION IS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF BOTH AIR
AND CLIMATE POLLUTION. IN FACT
VEHICLE POLLUTION KILLS MORE
PEOPLE EVERY YEAR THAT VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS DO. FORTUNATELY WE
HAVE A PART OF THE SOLUTION
WHICH IS GOING TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND THE STATE HAS A
VARIETY OF STANDARDS TO REQUIRE
A TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
CARS BUSES AND TRUCKS. WE THINK
THAT IT MAKES EXCELLENT SENSE
FOR THE STATE TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
. AND TO MOVE RAPIDLY TO CLEAN
UP ITS OWN FLEET OF VEHICLES AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA MEET
MULTIPLE FEDERAL AND STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS CRITICAL
TO IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. BY REQUIRING AT
LEAST 50% OF NEW HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES PURCHASED BY THE STATE
TO BE ZERO EMISSION BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. GROWING
TO A 100% OF NEW PURCHASES BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. AND ALSO
MOVING THE STATE'S LIGHT DUTY
FLEET 250% NEW PURCHASE IS BEING
ZERO EMISSION. BY JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR REACHING A
100% BY JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THERE VARIETY OF MODELS
THAT CAN SERVE THESE NEEDS- AND
ALL KNOW THAT OUR SUPPORT LETTER
IS ALSO JOINED BY ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. B. Y. D. NORTH
AMERICA. SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ALLIANCE
FOR CLEAN ECONOMY. THE CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
AMPLY THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS
MORE COLLABORATIVE EVEN Y. R.
KULTURA LET'S GREEN CALIFORNIA.
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND SERIES
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR
GAVIN MISTER READ FEEL FREE TO
BE YET. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
READ OUT A SUNDAY AFTER CAL
START HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY. THIS MEASURE BUILDS OFF A
LONG HISTORY OF THE STATE USING
ITS PURCHASING POWER TO HELP
DRIVE AND IMPLEMENT THE VARIOUS
POLICIES THE STATE HAS
INTRODUCED OVER THE YEARS. IN
PARTICULAR TRUCK GOING AND
TAKING THIS APPROACH ALLOWS THE
STATE AND ITS FLEET. TO BE ABLE
TO DRIVE DOWN EMISSIONS AND
SCALE UP THE INDUSTRY ULTIMATELY
ALLOWING THESE TYPES OF VEHICLES
TO BE CHEAPER AND MORE
ACCESSIBLE. FINALLY I WILL SAY
THAT BASED ON OUR MATH WE TAKE
WHEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED THIS
POLICY ALONE WILL DRIVE TWENTY
THOUSAND NEW VEHICLES THEIR
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD. AS FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SIR
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE CHAMBER UP
ABOVE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I SEE ONE
MORE. GOOD MORNING. HELLO I'M
CYNTHIA SHALLOT A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG. CAST OF COALITION OF
OVER EIGHTY FIVE CHAPTERS ACROSS
THOUSAND MEMBERS. I AM ACTIVE IN
CLIMATE JUSTICE WORKGROUP
BECAUSE WE THINK FIGHTING
CLIMATE. THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS
IMPORTANT ISSUES MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE HAVE. WITH A SPENT SOME
TIME EVALUATING THE VARIOUS
BILLS THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED.
AND I'M LEASED TO INFORM YOU
THAT WE RECENTLY VOTED TO SELECT
SB TEN TEN AS PRIORITY. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL. NOT ONLY IS IT
ESSENTIAL TO HELP CALIFORNIA
REACH ITS NET ZERO EMISSION
GOALS AND LIBERATE THE STATE
FROM FOSSIL FUEL DEPENDENCY. BUT
IT SETS AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
NATION IN THE WORLD. ALSO THE
STATE WILL SERVE AS A LEADER TO
OTHER GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES ON
HOW TO ACTUALLY TRANSITION THEIR
FLEETS TO ELECTRIC. I KNOW THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENCOUNTERED
SIGNIFICANT RESISTANCE FROM
THEIR FLEET MANAGERS SOMETIMES
ESPECIALLY FROM THEIR PUBLIC
SAFETY OPERATIONS. WITH THIS
BILL THE STATE CAN SHOW THE
LOCALS HOW IT IS DONE WHAT
MODELS CAN BE EFFICIENT AND
WHICH ONES CAN MEET THEIR
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT A POSSIBLE
LOOPHOLE IN THE BILL THAT ALLOWS
EXCEPTIONS FOR THOSE VEHICLES
THOSE VEHICLE PURCHASES. I HOPE
THE PROCESS FOR EVALUATING THE
USE OF EXCEPTIONS IS RIGOROUS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
MODERATOR- IT'S TIME TO MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR FIRST.
WOULD YOU PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN TEN. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
TENSION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. AND OUR
FIRST WITNESS IS- OUTLINE THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
BILL MURPHY REPRESENTING THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IS OVER
FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA'S OVER
ONE THOUSAND MEMBERS AND CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT SILICON VALLEY
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS IN STRONG
UPPORT. MOVING ALONG WITH OR
LIKE TWENTY THREE. A GOOD
MORNING- JULIE NOT OUT THE BALL
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO AMBER HOW THE
TRANSCRIPTS CONSULTING ON BEHALF
OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT OF SB CONTENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LIKE THIRTY SEVEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CATAMARAN WITH
THERE AND READING THIS POST GETS
REPRESENTING THE- LOCATION THE
PROFESSIONAL TRYING TO. THANK
YOU. OKAY ONE MORE REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
TENSION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FORTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. THIS IS SANTIAGO
CALIFORNIANS I'M INTO LOTUS
CALLING IN SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A
CREDO I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE ALREADY.
SURE MEMBERS DAN CHAU ON BEHALF
OF A RELIABLE AUTOMOTIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS A MINOR
LITTLE QUIRKS IN THE- DEFINITION
OF MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLES BUT- WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO RESOLVING
THAT- EXPEDITION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
ANOTHER ONE QUEUING UP WITH AN
OPERATOR. NOBODY ELSE GOING AT
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU UP ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CATHY SEE FIRSTHAND
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MISTER SHARE WE HAVE
ADOPTED THE KILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I WOULD I'M- MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WOULD HAVE TESTIFIED-
IN OPPOSITION S. B. TEN TEN IS
THERE ANYBODY ABOVE SEEING
NOBODY- MODERATOR LET'S STUFF
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
BOTTERILL ARE YOU WITH ME. YES I
AM SO SORRY MEASURE WAS INCLUDED
ON THE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS SB TEN TEN SB TEN TEN AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. YOU AND
NOBODY IS KILLING UP. OKAY
THANKS TO ALL OUR SUPPORT-
WITNESSES WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS ON
THIS ISSUE I SEE CENTER BOARD
JUST. MICROPHONE IS UP PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIR- JUST A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. THE AUTHOR
BY MAY- WHEN WE REFER TO A
MEDIUM AND HEAVY VEHICLE FLEET.
OF VEHICLES- ARE WE ALSO DOES
THIS ALSO APPLY TO. BUY
CALIFORNIA ENTITIES LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IN CALIFORNIA
GUARD. PERMISSION TO RESPOND
PLEASE THIS IS ONLY STATE
PURCHASES IT IS NOT SCHOOL
DISTRICT PURCHASES SO- IT IS
PURELY THE PURCHASES OF STATE
VEHICLE FLEETS BY DGS. WITH THAT
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA GUARD. IT
THE AGENCIES THAT IT WOULD
INCLUDE OUR- THE HIGHWAY PATROL
pREHABILITATION TRANSPORTATION
FISHING WILDLIFE PARKS AND REC
CONSUMER AFFAIRS I DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE NATIONAL
GUARD BUT I DON'T HAVE IT ON OUR
LIST AS BEING ONE OF THE
AGENCIES SO I AM THINKING NOT
BUT I WILL MAKE SURE TO FIND OUT
AND GET BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE. I'LL TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I'D I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT BILL I REALLY LOOK TO
THE STATE TO BE A LEADER IN THIS
AREA AND WE HAVE POLICIES THAT
WERE MAKING BUSINESSES STEP UP
TO THE PLATE IN INVEST IN THE
NEW GREEN ECONOMY IF YOU WILL
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IT
OUGHT TO WE OUGHT TO BE SETTING
THE EXAMPLE I WILL SAY- WITHOUT.
TOUCHING IT TO ANY SPECIFICS I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A REAL I DON'T
KNOW IF IT COULD BE PART OF THIS
BILL A ROBUST. THE ROBUST
STATIONS THAT REQUIRED THAT
REALLY ALLOW VEHICLES
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT CALTRANS CHP WE'VE GOT WE
CAN'T DEAL WITH YEAH LEVEL ONE
LEVEL TWO PROBABLY THE LEVEL
THREE CHARGERS THESE ARE GOING
TO REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY CHARTERS.
I GET THE THUMBS UP FROM CENTER
HERTZBERG THERE OKAY PERFECT-
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING ON THIS ONE
. SEEING NONE I CENTER SKINNER
WHICH LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I THINK YOUR
POINT IS WELL THE BILL IS SILENT
AROUND THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE CLEARLY IF THE
STATE MOVES IN THIS DIRECTION IT
WILL HAVE TO- HAVE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
OUR STATE FLEETS. ONCE THEY ARE
SET UP WILL HAVE TO BE CHARGED
AND- THE BENEFIT OF. AS HAS BEEN
STATED NOT ONLY BY YOU MISTER
CHAIR BUT BY ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IS THAT THE GOOD THING
OF. THE STATE LEADING BY EXAMPLE
IS THAT NUMBER ONE BECAUSE THE
STATE IN A FLEET PURCHASE BUYS A
LOT OF VEHICLES AT ONCE IT CAN
NEGOTIATE A YOU KNOW A BETTER
PRICE THAN YOU KNOW WE AS
INDIVIDUALS. AND BY PURCHASING
LARGE VOLUMES OF DESERVES IT
DOES SEND OUT MARKET SIGNAL TO.
TO BRING THE PRICE DOWN BECAUSE
IT INCREASES THE DEMAND. AND TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
MODELS AS WELL AS INCREASING THE
INVESTMENT IN CHARGING WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL BE CHARGING THAT
OTHER PEOPLE CAN USE
ADDITIONALLY. SO I AM THAT'S
CERTAINLY THE INTENT OF THE BILL
AND DIE WITH THAT I ASK YOUR
ABOUT. THANK YOU CENTER SCARED
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB TEN TEN.
CENTER ARCHULETA THANK YOU- THE
BILL'S BEEN NEW BIKES- CENTER
ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DODD HI DONNA HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN- ALLEN ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I. MERGERS
BORDERS I BRADFORD GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WESSEL. WESEL II
JONES JONES NO KAMLAGER MELENDEZ
. MELENDEZ NO PORTANTINO RUBIO
WILK WELL I WILK I THE LAST.
SEVEN TWO THREE ON SEVENTY THREE
WILL PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL. WE
WILL NOW- MOVED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN. I AM READY. THAT OPEN
UP THE FILE FOR YOUR BILL AND
PRESENTING BUT I'M READY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. RUBBER
THING NOW AND FOREVER. YOU KNOW
CAN I TELL YOU SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS. YOU CAN-
IN OTHER WORKING ON BLOCKCHAIN
SO I GOT HERE. AND I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT HOW THEY TALK
ABOUT BLOCKCHAIN I WANTED TO
STAND ON THIS FLOOR OF THE
SENATE THE OTHER WORD COMMITTEE
NOW AND TALK ABOUT BLOCKCHAIN
BECAUSE WHEN I STARTED WORK AT
MOST PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS THE
FENCE AROUND THE SWIMMING POOL
AND DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND.
THE SOPHISTICATION AND WHAT IT
WAS NOT WORKING SO I INTRODUCED
A BILL SOME YEARS AGO. IT WAS
PASSED THIS HOUSE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR THAT WITH. ON
GETTING INVENTORY OF VARIOUS-
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BEGIN THE
FRAME THAT OUT. AND THEN I ALSO
DID A BLOCKCHAIN BILL. BUT
BASICALLY THAT TLKED ABOUT
CORPORATIONS THAT COULD THEN PUT
THEIR STOCK CERTIFICATES IN THE
BLOCKCHAIN TO PRESENT AGAINST
FRAUD. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THEN
MAJORITY LEADER- IAN CALDERON
WHO DID IT THE STATE A BASIC
STUDY GROUP WORKING GROUP BOTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON MISTER
ALAN AND I WERE INVOLVED IN AND
WE PUT TOGETHER THE GREATEST
EXPERTS AROUND THE STATE AND
THEN BERKELEY A NUMBER OF TIMES.
AND THEY MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE
SHOULD DO WITH RESPECT TO MOVING
THE DISCUSSION IN GOVERNMENT THE
FORWARD ON BLOCKCHAIN. AND WE'RE
NOT THE FIRST SURPRISING TO SAY
WITH RESPECT TO ADOPTING
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY WYOMING.
THE GREAT STATE OF WYOMING THIS
LARK THAT'S SMALLER THAN CENTER
ARE JEWELERS DISTRICT CURRENTLY
PERMITS THE USE OF BLOCKCHAIN
STATE GOVERNMENT AUTHORIZES
SECRETARY OF STATE. IMPLEMENT
BLOCKCHAIN BASED COMMERCIAL
FILINGS. COLORADO WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE SIZE OF A COUPLE OF
SENATE DISTRICTS HERE. PASS
LEGISLATION TO EXPLORE THE USE
OF BLOCKCHAIN TO SECURELY
TRANSFER RECORDS. BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES AND PER CONFIDENTIAL
DATA. THE PRIVATE SECTOR
DEPARTMENT STORES USING
BLOCKCHAINS NOW TO CREATE SHARED
LEDGERS AND INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN MERCHANT
SHIPPERS. AND PURCHASERS TO
ELIMINATE INVOICE DISPUTES AND
SOME GROCERY PROVIDERS COFFEE.
AND OTHERS USING BLOCKCHAINS
DEPLOY FOOD TRACEABILITY SYSTEMS
TO INCREASE PRODUCT TRACING AND
THE COST. OF FOOD BORNE
ILLNESSES AND CONTAMINATION SO.
IT'S THE STARTED ON PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY THE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY AS I
SAY WE SUGGESTED BY THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BLOCKCHAIN
WORKING GROUP. THAT MAJORITY
LEADER CALDERON AND I WERE PART
OF. AND SO WHAT ARE WE DOING
<c.red>ERE TODAY IN MOVING THIS DEBATE</c>
FORWARD. ARMED THIS IS AIMED AT
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
COMING FROM THE BLOCKCHAIN. A
WORKING GROUP IN A DEALS WITH
VERIFIED CREDENTIALS. VERIFIED
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS ARE PART
OF OUR DAILY LIFE THINK FOR
EXAMPLE OF. A DRIVER'S LICENSE
WE USED TO- A WE CAN DRIVE A CAR
PASSED TO BLESSED TRAVEL
COUNTRIES HIGH SCHOOL
TRANSCRIPTS THAT ARE USED TO
IMPROVE OUR EDUCATIONAL LEVEL
COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
VERIFYING THESE CREDENTIALS ARE
MEMBERS IS OFTEN A TIME
CONSUMING PAPER BASED PROCESS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE SECURITY
ELECTRONIC CREDENTIALS ARE SEEN
AS TOO EASILY FORGED AND
UNRELIABLE BLOCKCHAIN BASED
CREDENTIALS. CAN HELP REMOVE
FRICTION THAT ENABLES SECURING
SHOWING UP ONLINE CREDENTIALS
VERIFIED FOR PROOF UNDER THE
INDIVIDUALS CONTROL SO THIS
MEASURE DOES TWO THINGS ONE IT
CREATES THE CALIFORNIA TRUST
REMARK. TO ENSURE THE USE OF
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS ON TO A
STANDARD RECOGNIZED BY BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR TAKES
US DOWN THE ROAD THE NEXT STEP.
IT IS TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENGAGES IN THIS AND THEN IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR A- ARE ON THE ABILITY
IN PARTICULAR LIKE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHERE THEY CAN USE THE
BLOCKCHAIN TO VERIFY THE HIGH
SCHOOL. RECORDS AS THEY WANT TO
MOVE ON TO USE THEM FOR OTHER
PURPOSES COLLEGE OR THE LIKE
AGAIN TRYING TO EDUCATE THE NEXT
GENERATION IN THAT REGARD SO
TODAY. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MAY. IS CLEAN OR- WITHDRAW- IP
FOUNDATION AND TONI ROSE WITH IT
WITH INPUT OUTPUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THIS CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AS FOR SUPPORTERS MEASURE THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG MISLI. NOR-
YOU CAN BEGIN. AT A MEETING AND
CHAIRMAN DODDLE. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK INTO OF SB
ELEVEN NINETY. I AM JUDITH
CLEANER DIRECTOR OF. ENGAGEMENT
FOR THE TRUCK OVER I. T. FOR.
CALLING MARIE CALIFORNIA.
RUSTENBURG PGM BASED
ORGANIZATION WITH OVER FOUR
HUNDRED CORPORATE AND INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERS. WE ARE COMMUNITY
CREATING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
INTEROPERABLE TRUST FRAMEWORKS
SUCH AS THE ONE THATWILL BE
CREATED WHEN THIS BILL IF PASSED
. FIRST LET'S START WITH THE
PROBLEM. WHEN THE INTERNET WAS
INITIALLY DEVELOPED IT WAS
DIVINE INTERCONNECT MACHINES TO
SHARE INFORMATION ACROSS THE
NETWORK. THE INTERNET PROTOCOL
TELLS YOU NOTHING ABOUT THE
PERSON THE ORGANIZATION OR THE
THING RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
CONNECTION. THE INTERNET WITH A
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL BUT WE BUILT
ALL THE SYSTEMS YOU BUSINESS
INTERACTIONS OVER IT BUT WE-
AUTHENTICATING THE USER. THE
DREADED NAME A PASS LOG IN WITH
BORN. IN ADDITION TO THE PRIVACY
AND SECURITY ISSUES WITH
PASSWORD BIG DON'T REPLICATE HOW
CREDENTIALS WORK IN THE REAL
WORLD. IN THE REAL WORLD THE
CREDENTIALS ISSUED. SOME ELEMENT
THAT DESIGNATE AS BEING FROM A
BALLOT ISSUE ONE. A. DRIVER'S
LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE HAVE A
RECOGNIZABLE FORMAT WITH
SECURITY FEATURES BUT IN ABLE
ITS AUTHENTICITY TO BE VALIDATED
. ONCE ISSUED THE HOLDER CAN GO
AND USE IT WHEREVER THEY WANT.
IT IS SIX BY MULTIPLE PARTIES AS
A BALLOT BY DESIGN WITHOUT A
PARTY LEADING TO GO BACK TO THE
ISSUER. WITH THE ADVENT OF
MODERN CRYPTOGRAPHY WE NOW HAVE
A WAY TO DO THE SAME THING WITH
DIGITAL CREDENTIAL. OUR PARTY
THAT NEEDS TO VERIFY THE
AUTHENTICITY OF THE CREDENTIALS
TO DO THAT WITH DON'T NEED TO
PHONE HOME TO A CENTRAL SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL A
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS. BOARD IF
YOU COULD TAKE A VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS OF THEIR TRANSCRIPT.
ISSUED TO THEM BY THE HIGH
SCHOOL TO DO ANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THEY WANT AND THE
COLLEGE CAN VERIFY THAT IT IS
AUTHENTIC. THIS IS EXACTLY THE
USE CASE THIS BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE VIA APPHIGHLY PROJECT
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEAD A PATH FOR OTHER STATES TO
FOLLOW. ALL THE WHILE PROTECTING
THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THE TRACTOR RIDE
P. FOUNDATION APPLAUDS SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT WILL TORRENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I
PERJURE BY VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISLEADING
THIS FLAME LEONORE- LET'S
CONTINUE WITH MR ROSE POLICE
DISTROS ARE YOU'RE ON. GOOD
MORNING. IT SEEMS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND CHAIRMAN DOT THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN NINETY.
I'M TWENTY ROADS AND HAPPEN BAY
CALIFORNIA AND HEAD OF PRODUCT
DID IDENTITY FOR INPUT UP A
GLOBAL OR I. G. FOR SHORT. I. G.
DEVELOPS HE'S TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE R. G. ALSO
CREATED THE BLOCKCHAIN NETWORKS-
DANO. VIRTUAL CURRENCY ADA.
DONNA MOVED TWEEN THE TOP THREE
AND TOP OF ALL BLOCKCHAIN THAT'S
GOING TO WRAP. WITH A ENTERED
EFFICIENT APPROACH WHAT ME MOST
ABOUT THIS THE ABILITY TO DETECT
. IN A WAY THAT UNLOCKS ABILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS. I KNOW THE
TECHNOLOGY CAN PROVIDE GREAT
BENEFITS WHEN INACTION. IN A
ROLL OF AS HEAD OF PRODUCT AND
I- G. WE ARE DEPLOYING A DIGITAL
IDENTITY SOLUTIONS. FIVE MILLION
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN ETHIOPIA
WE ARE PARTNERED WITH THE
MINISTRY OF EDUCATION. NECW IN
ORDER TO CREATE A SYSTEM FOR
STUDENTS THAT WOULD OFFER
GREATER FLEXIBILITY THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIVES. DURING THE FALL WE
WENT ONE. ELEVEN GREATER AND-
OVER THE NEXT FIVE. THE BILL
BECAUSE STARTING WITH HIGH
DIPLOMA. EXPANDING TO HIGH YOU.
AND OTHER CAREER PATHWAYS AND
EVENTUALLY FINANCIAL SERVICES.
HE'LL BE A MANY OTHER COUNTRIES
CANADA UNITED KINGDOM GERMANY
SINGAPORE NEW ZEALAND AND
AUSTRALIA. ARE STARTING TO
DOCTORS FRAMEWORKS. IT'S AN
EQUAL PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE PA
AND PRIVATE SECTORS THREE MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
MOVE THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES WITH
THE BENEFIT OF OWNING HOLDING
AND CONTROLLING THEIR DIGITAL
IDENTITY DATA. THANK YOU MOST
ABOUT SB ELEVEN. THAT IT PAST A
DEFENDER HERE WILL BE ON THE
PATH TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ON. HOLD CONTROL AFTER RECORDS.
ACCESS INTERNATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WITH MORE EASE
BASED UPON THE RECOGNIZE HIGH
QUALITY OF EDUCATION WE PROVIDE
A BEAUTIFUL THICK. NOT ONLY THAT
WE WILL BE A PLACE STUDENTS
AROUND THE- AND FURTHER THERE
AND- WITH THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
ACADEMIC CREDENTIALS THEY'RE
EARNING BACK HOME. MEET OUR
STANDARDS AND WILL BE ACCEPTED
HERE. POSTED TO THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STATE AND MEGAN OUR ECONOMY
ONE OF THE STRONGEST IN THE
WORLD. WHAT BILL CALIFORNIA HAS
. TO MEET A PATH FOR OTHER STATE
COUNTRIES TO FALL. ALL OF
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY RIGHT TO
CALL. I PERSONAL. AND ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUES I L. G. A PLUG
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR BRING THIS
IS- FOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
TIME NEVER HEARD YOUR VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT. I THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO ANYONE IN THE T. WHO
WON TO TEST TO WE DO HAVE ONE
PURSUE. MISTER CHAIRMAN RESULTS
STORES WAS STRATEGIES SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF BLOCK INFORMALLY
SQUARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
KNOWLEDGEABLE TO WITNESS WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
REVERSE MODERATOR WHICH PLEASE
PROPPED INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN TO TEST FIND SUPPORT
THESE PRESS S. B. R. FOR SB TEN.
FOR NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND WE WERE LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JEANNIE MINOR
ON BEHALF OF THE BLOCKCHAIN AT.
CHOLISH THE POWER ON THE BILL
AND HAPPY SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS A
ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY SUPPORT. I
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR- WE'RE GONNA OPEN I'VE
WE'RE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THE CHAMBERS WHICH MACHINE
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. BEING
DONE YOU NOW MOVE ON- IT OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THAT
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION SB
ELEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN A TEST IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN NINETY THREE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED
BY. ZERO MR SURE NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TO OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK HERE
TO THE MEMBERS ANYBODY WISHING
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE HERE.
I'M NOT SEEN ANY- MIKE'S UP-
WITH THAT- CENTER HERTZBERG
WHICH LIKE CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE GOVERNOR.
HAS MADE HIS MARK ON BEING
INNOVATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
TECHNOLOGY AND GOVERNMENT
INTERFACE AND CREATED
DEPARTMENTS. THAT THE MISSION OF
MAKING TECHNOLOGY MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
FOR EXAMPLE OF THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION UNDER GOV OPS
THIS WILL BOLSTER THAT EFFORT.
YOU KNOW IT'S WE ALL BECOME MORE
AND MORE DEPENDENT ON THE
INTERNET WILL ALSO BE TO HACKING
WE SEE THE STORIES OF
RANSOMWARE. AND ALL THE
CHALLENGE THAT HOSPITALS AND
BANKS AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS
FACE WHEN THEY GET HACKED. THAT
CAN'T HAPPEN WITH THE
BLOCKCHAIN. THE BLOCKCHAIN IS TO
SECURE I GUESS UNTIL IT DOES BUT
SO FAR THERE'S NO TECHNOLOGY TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT. AND SO WE NEED
TO BE SMARTER WE NEED TO BE
AHEAD OF THE GAME WE NEED TO
INVENT THE FUTURE. THAT IS OUR
JOB WE MEET THE CHALLENGES OF
THE DAY HERE IN THIS JOB IN THIS
CHAMBER IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO BE FORWARD
THINKING. DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
ASKED ME WHERE DO YOU GET THESE
IDEAS FROM. YOU GET THEM FROM
CREATIVE INVENTIVE PEOPLE. AND
YOU TRY TO INTEGRATE GOVERNMENT
IN THE WAY TO MAKE IT WORK. AND
IF IT DOESN'T YOU FIGURE IT OUT
YOU FIX IT YOU COURSE CORRECT
AND YOU KEEP MOVING FORWARD
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUCH A GREAT
PLACE. AND WITH THAT I ASK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEM FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG- WE HAVE A MOTION ON
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY. WAS ABER
CENTER BORDERS OKAY- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DODD BY DOT I'D
NIELSEN. NIELSEN I ALLEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BAKER
BORDERS. BORDERS AYE BRADFORD
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE WESSEL HUESO
AYE JONES JONES HI KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK. WELL I.
TEN ZERO SHERMAN ON CALL. THAT'S
IT IN A CENTER HERTZBERG THE
BILL BEYOND GRADUATION. RICHARD
MY DEEP RESPECT THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY BY SENATOR HUESO. CENTER
HUESO YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. WHICH ANYWAY. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AT TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY WHICH WOULD CREATE AN
EXEMPTION TO TIED HOUSE LAWS
ALLOWING SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY TO ENTER INTO
SPONSORSHIP AGREEMENTS ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE. AT ITS NEW SNAP GREG
DRAGON STADIUM AND OTHER VENUES
ACROSS STADIUM IN CASE MANY OF
YOU ARE NOT AWARE SAN DIEGO
STATE IS LEADING. A LARGE
REDEVELOPMENT IN A MISSION A
MISSION VALLEY PARCEL THAT WILL
CREATE A NEW STADIUM NEW STUDENT
HOUSING. AND FACILITIES THAT
SPAN. THE OF THE DELIVERY OF
EDUCATION IN THIS WONDERFUL
UNIVERSITY THIS- WINNING LOTS OF
AWARDS IN IN ITS RANKINGS AND
IT'S JUST A QUALITY INSTITUTION
. WHAT DOES THE ISSUE LIKE OTHER
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE
ALREADY HAS A RETAIL LICENSE AND
HAS TRIED HANS EXEMPTIONS FOR
OTHER FACILITIES THEY HAVE-
BASKETBALL ARENA THE TONY GWYNN
BASEBALL STADIUM THE AZTECS
SOFTBALL STADIUM AND A POOR
PERFORMING ARTS VENUE. THE BUCK
CAL COAST OPEN AIR THEATRE THIS
WAS SIMPLY EXTEND THOSE TRYING
TO HOUSE EXEMPTIONS TO THE NEW
FACILITY WHICH IS- OFF CAMPUS
THE CREATE NEW CAMPUS CONNECTED-
BUT IN ADDITION TO THE ROSE BY A
TROLLEY- BY- A MASTERY. SO THIS
WHOLE GREATLY ENHANCE. THE
UNIVERSITY'S ABILITY TO DEVELOP
THIS FACILITY WITH A PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS ED AND SO
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
DEVELOPMENT OF COURSE THIS IS A
VERY- NECESSARY COMPONENT BRING.
THIS PROJECT INTO COMPLETE
FRUITION AND NASPERS TODAY. AT
AS FAR WE HAVE ON THE LINE TO
TEST PLAN SUPPORT MENU MEASURE-
JOHN DAVID WICKER HIS TO DETER
DIRECTOR OF INTERCOLLEGIATE
ATHLETICS FIRST AS A NEW STATE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE GINA JACOBS HIS
THE ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE MISSION VALLEY DEVELOPMENT
SDSU. OKAY MISTER WICKER YOU CAN
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING DODD IN
NUMBERS MY NAME IS JD WORKER IN
I'M THE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR FOR
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY TODAY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE EIGHTY A MEASURE ABOUT
THE NATURE HUESO THAT CREATES AN
EXEMPTION TO TIED HOUSE LAWS THE
MOLE OUT THEN YOU GO STATE
UNIVERSITY TO ENTER SPORTFISHING
AGREEMENTS WITH ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
SUPPLIERS AT THE NEW SNAPDRAGON
. IN OTHER AND THE ISSUE OF THEM
BEING USED AS THE ISSUE WITH THE
OLDEST UNIVERSITY IN SAN DIEGO
WITH THE MISSION TO PROVIDE
RESEARCH ORIENTED HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SOLUTION OF
THE PROBLEM EXCELLENT
DISTINCTION IN TEACHING RESEARCH
AND SERVICE. SB ISSUE MISSION
VALLEY AND THE ADDITION OF
SNAPDRAGON X. STADIUM ONE HAS
OUR STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE CREATE A REGIONAL
ASSET FOR THE ENTIRE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY WHEN THE STADIO
STADIUM OPENS THIS FALL THEY
WILL HAVE A RETAIL LIFE. DON'T
HAVE A HOLIDAY. BEVERAGE
REBRANDING OF COUP AGAINST THE-
THAN A- WITH THE EXECUTIVE OR
ELEVEN NINE. THANK TIED HOW LAWS
. ALCOHOL BEVERAGE SUPPLIER
REMAIN. FROM SPOT. IN THEN. OR
OTHER I. THAT ARE. WHY FOR. THIS
PREVENTS THAT ISSUES BEING FOR
MANY INTO. AGREE WITHOUT A
STASHED EXEMPTION. THE ISSUE
MISSION VALLEY IS ON THE SAME
SIDE. AS THE FORMER QUALCOMM
STADIUM WHICH HAD A SEVENTY
THOUSAND THE CAPACITY IN
ADVERTISING FOR ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. THE CAPACITY FOR THE
NEW STADIUM IS THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND THE REQUEST FOR A
NEW EXEMPTION DID NOT INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES ADVERTISING IN THE
STATE THAT HAS SPORTS
BACKTRACKING STADIUM WILL SERVE
AS A HOME FOR SDSU ATHLETICS AND
THE GOAL IS TO UTILIZE. ALL YEAR
ROUND FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SPECIAL EVENTS FOR SAN DIEGANS.
WE'RE SEEKING AN URGENT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT DURING STADIUM IS
SCHEDULED TO OPEN ON SEPTEMBER
THIRD FOR THE AZTECS FOOTBALL
SEASON OPENER. YOU CAN SHOW
ENOUGH. OF THE STATE THAT'S NOT
RELY ANY STATE. IT SUPPORT
FINANCE. SB TWELVE A SIX DIRECT
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT IS OUT.
EXEMPTION PERSON SPECIFIC ARENA
STADIUMS AND ENTERTAINMEN
COMPLEXES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SB TWELVE IF NEED IN ORDER TO
ALLOW WINERIES AND PRODUCERS AND
ALSO. OF ALCOHOLIC THAT THE-
SNAPDRAGON. ON THROUGH SPONSORS
AND ADVERTISING THE- IT WILL
SPONSORS ACROSS MULTIPLE THE-
WHICH- ENHANCE SPONSORSHIP VALUE
BUYING. THE AND DIVERSITY OF
SPECTATOR. VIEWING THE
ADVERTISING. IMPORTANTLY
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT SUCH AS
THE- OF RESPONSIBLE CONSUMPTION
PROGRAM THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY
WILL BE A FIRM REQUIREMENT IS
PART OF THE OUT. THAT COMPANIES
ARE. THAT STADIUM ALSO BE HOME
TO PROFESSIONAL SPORTS. FROM THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S SOCCER LEAGUE
AND MAJOR LEAGUE RUGBY. SB
ISSUES STILL ACTIVELY SEEKING
OTHER PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE PLAN. STADIUM
THE ABILITY YOU CAN MONICA THE
ALCOHOL CATEGORY WHEN DONE
APPROACH. FOR ABOUT SPONSORED
AND IS CRUCIAL FOR SECURING
PARTNERS SOME OF. AN IMPORTANT
STILL. TO ENHANCE ARGUED TO
EDUCATE LOOKS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AND I WAS REQUEST YOUR AYE
THOSE ON EIGHT TWELVE EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER WICKER LET'S
CONTINUE WITH THE MISS JACOB.
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE. I
MORNING CARE DIED AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE NINE ACRE THANK.
YOU BYE PRESIDENT CRACKED YET
THE MISSION VALLEY I MEAN I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU- NOW- WILL
MOVE ON ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO WANTS TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS GEN CHASE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SPONSORING
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO ALEX- MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES. WAITING TESTIFY BY
TELE MODERATOR. CAN WE GET
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. TWELVE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU YES YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY I HAVE NO WANTING TO
ASSIST. VERY GOOD I WAS WORRIED
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WAITING TO APPLY IT AND GET ON
THE- CONFERENCE LINE SO- NOW IS
THERE ANYBODY- WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION HERE. SEEN
NONE- ANYBODY ON THE-
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS- MODERATOR
. WICHITA COUNTY DOES YOUR-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
DO IT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE MEMBERS A CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU AT YOUR DOT- I
DON'T KNOW IF EVERYONE IN THE
CHAMBER MAYBE EVEN ON THE PHONE
LINES THOUGH SOME OF THE HISTORY
OF PASSING INDIGO STATE. AND
ALCOHOL SERVICE BUT IT WAS ABOUT
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND THE
DEBATE WAS ABOUT WHETHER BILLION
BEER SHOULD BE ALLOWED AND
MONIES DAN- AND THAT'D NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE- THAT
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION RESULTED
IN A RESPONSIBLE ALCOHOL SALES
AT THAT TIME AND I THINK IT IS
CONTINUED. THE UNIVERSITY IS
VERY ATTENTIVE TO WHAT HOW TO DO
THESE THINGS RIGHT- CERTAINLY
HAS A PROUD ALUMNI OF SAN DIEGO
STATE. I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPENING OF THE STADIUM AND ALL
THE OTHER. VENUES IN WHICH THIS
WOULD BE I BELIEVE RESPONSIBLY
DI<c.cyan> HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL</c>
AND MOVE THE BILL THE PROPER
TIME. THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
WISHING TO TESTIFY SAYING- SO
THEY'RE GLAZER HOW MANY YEARS
WERE YOU ON CAMPUS AFTER THAT
WAS PASSED IN IF YOU HAVE A
BEER- IN THE DEN I OF COURSE I
NEED TO WHICH I WAS TWENTY ONE
SIR TO- BE ABLE TO. HAVE IT WHEN
I WAS STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT I
WASN'T TWENTY ONE YET BUT I DID
COME BACK AND ENJOY IT AND SEE
IF THE RESPONSIBLENESS OF THE
CAMPUS UP RUNNING CLOSE. THAT I
THANK YOU THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR GLAZER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER HUESO.
YES THANK YOU THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY CSU THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. WE ARE ALSO SEEKING
AN URGENCY CLAUSE BECAUSE THE
SNAPDRAGON STADIUM. IS SCHEDULED
TO OPEN ON SEPTEMBER THIRD. FOR
THE AZTEC FOOTBALL SEASON OPENER
SO THEY'RE WORKING HARD TO GET
READY FOR THAT. AND WILL
HOPEFULLY. ARE- OF. LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS ON THIS BILL COULD BE
SUMMED UP SOONER. RATHER THAN
LATER SO WE CAN GET THIS BILL.
THANK HUESO SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DODD I DODD AYE
NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE ALLEN. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA ARCHULETA ALRIGHT
BAKER BORJAS. GORGEOUS HIGH
BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER AYE
WESSEL WESSEL II JONES. JONES I
. MELENDEZ PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK
WILK HI. NINE ZERO CHAIRMAN ON
CALL THAT WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT
ANIMAL COSTS GOT NINE VOTES THAT
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN OH FIVE BY
SENATOR LATER. SAID EARLIER YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND GOOD MORNING TO THE
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ARM
IN SHORT THE STATE'S CURRENT
EVALUATION METHODOLOGY FOR LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE CONTRACTS WAS LAST
UPDATED IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
WHEN THE STATE WAS PURCHASING
LARGE NUMBERS OF FLEX FUEL
VEHICLES THIS BILL SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH FIVE WILL MOVE THE
STATE'S CONTRACT PROCESS TO THE
CURRENT STATE OF PLAY. OF BY
UPDATING AND SIMPLIFYING THE
PROCESS FOR AWARDING STATE
CONTRACTS FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES INCLUDING HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL VEHICLES PLUG IN HYBRID AND
HYBRID ELECTRIC VEHICLES
CURRENTLY STATE LAW ALLOWS THAT
AT LEAST 50% OF THE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES PURCHASED FOR THE STATE
FOR EACH YEAR BE ZERO EMISSION
BY. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EARLIER
TODAY YOU HEARD- SENATE BILL TEN
TEN BY SENATOR SKINNER WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE 100% OF THE LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES BE ZERO EMISSION
BY A TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
HOWEVER THE STATUTES STILL
REQUIRES AN ELABORATE
METHODOLOGY DESIGNED TO WEIGH
THE MERITS OF DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVE FUELS. THIS DEALS
WITH THAT PROCESS BY WHICH A WAR
ARE MADE BY MODERNIZE THE
CURRENT STATUTE THE EXISTING
METHODOLOGY WILL STILL CONTINUE
TO BE USED FOR VEHICLES POWERED
SOLELY BY INTERNET INTERNAL
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES SINCE THE
ANALYSIS MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED
A SUPPORT LETTER FROM PLUG IN
AMERICA. A NONPROFIT SUPPORTER
DRIVEN ADVOCACY GROUP- AND WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
WHOSE LETTER- ABOUT THIS BILL IS
ON THE WAY INSTANTIATE FROM
ARRIVAL AUTOMOTIVE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SO FOR THE WHAT
THE WITNESS YOU CAN THERE'S
NOBODY UP HERE. WITNESS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE I PLEASE PURSUE.
THRILLER I DIDN'T GET HER NAME
I'M SORRY IT'S DAN CHIA ADULT
YOU SURE YEAH MR CHIA ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. WELL I HAVE. MODERATOR
IF MR G. E. GO AHEAD. YES
BECAUSE I DO NOT SEE THEM ONLINE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA START-
WITH WITNESSES WAITING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS CAN YOU
PROP THURMOND. AND THE- MOVE ON
WITH WITNESSES TESTING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN OH
FIVE TESTIFIED THAT IS. YES
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE THREE ZERO FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TO GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
FIVE PLEASE BEGIN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS DAN SHARP. WHO'S
THIS. JUST ONE MORE MOMENT.
BUILDING A LAST MILE DELIVERY
VAN AND TRANSIT BUS. I WAS
EXCITED TO BEGIN DELIVERING ITS
FIRST OF THOUSANDS OF BANDS TO
U. P. S. BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
AND IS LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
THOSE VEHICLES ON CALIFORNIA
ROADS. SB THIRTEEN OH FIVE THE
SIMPLE COMMONSENSE UPDATED YOUR
BGS PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY
REFLECTS THE COMMERCIAL
AVAILABILITY OF THAT TECHNOLOGY
. IT WILL ALSO RESULT IN MORE
EFFICIENT PROCUREMENT OF SAYS
AND HOPEFULLY SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS STRONGLY YOU'RE SUPPORT
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED FOR A
UPON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS COULD YOU YOUR IN
VOICE IS. THANK YOU- ANYBODY
ALSO A MODERATOR. YES NEXT TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BILL WORKING
REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY IS OVER FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OWNERS PLANET ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA'S OVER ONE THOUSAND
MEMBERS REQUIRED REALITY
PROJECTS SILICON VALLEY IS FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS IN SUPPORT. NEXT
CALLER. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THANK YOU NATIONAL ALLY NUMBER
THIRTY PLEASE AGAIN. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS PACK BROWN WITH
THEIR IN READING OF SUCH HIS
GROUP REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR- ADULTS
LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ANY- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HERE
OF THE CHAMBER. SO WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AT THIS POINT MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
OH FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE THREE
ZERO FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CONNECT ONE.
OPPOSITION. AND CURRENTLY WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS. ANY
MEMBERS SEVEN ARCHULETA YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR ON SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH FIVE AND THAT'S THAT
I BE ON A CO CHAIR- IT'S
EXCITING TO SEE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN UP THE TREASURE CHEST OF
ENERGY TO INCLUDE ALL SOURCES OF
ENERGY AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FUEL CELL HYDROGEN IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE INCLUDE THAT
IN OUR FUTURE AND- HOPEFULLY IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE WILL HAVE-
ONE DAY A THOUSAND. US STATIONS
WHERE- PRIVATE VEHICLES STATE
VEHICLES CAN BE- AND ON THE ROAD
SO THIS IS A START AND- I
CERTAINLY WILL SUPPORT IT AND
DEAD LIKE TO MOVE THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK CENTER
ARE EXCELLENT I THINK YOU MET CO
AUTHOR NOT CO CHAIR SO THATS
JULIE NOTED ALSO FOR THE RECORD
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON WAS SUPPORTING IN- ON THE
TELECONFERENCE THAT WAS. P. AND
G. WHO'S CENTER LARGE SAID WOULD
BE. THERE JUST ON A DIFFERENT
LINE- SO THE- THE BILL HAS BEEN
. MOVED CENTER ARCHULETA- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE EARLIER HI I
THANK THE PEOPLE THAT TESTIFIED
ON A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LEHRER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATOR ARCHULETA.
CENTER ARCHULETA WOULD I SAY YES
I MOVE IT NORTH. LOOK THANK YOU
CENTER IT'S BEEN MOVED CENTER
ARCHULETA SECTOR I CALL THE ROLL
DOT BY THOUGHT I'D NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE ALLEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BAKER
BORDERS. BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER
I WENT SO. WEST HI JONES JONES I
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK. WELCOME HI. THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO TERMINAL CALL EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL CENTER-
MCGUIRE IS NOT HERE SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL- WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR DOLLINGER. THIRD DOLLAR
YOU MAY BEGIN. DAVID SHERMAN
MEMBERS- I'VE HERE TO PRESENT SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO FIRST I WANT
TO TAKE THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I DON'T THINK THE
CHAIR KAREN COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE AGENCIES COMMITTEE.
STAFF AND PROVIDING SUGGESTIONS
AMENDMENTS AND ACCEPT AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS. UP FOR THE FIRST TWO
YEARS THE- RESTAURANT AND FOOD
INDUSTRIES HAVE SUFFERED IMMENSE
LOSS OF CUSTOMERS REVENUE
EMPLOYEES DUE TO THE FALL. OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS.
MANY WERE FORCED TO CLOSE WHILE
OTHERS HAD TO PIVOT TO MAINTAIN
SOME PROPER ABILITY OR JUST TO
STAY IN BUSINESS. ONE OF THOSE
MORE PROFITABLE FUTURES. OF THE
BUSINESSES ARE THEIR ALCOHOL
SALES WHICH IN SOME CASES HELP
THEM- WHETHER THE CODED A STORM
IN ELDORADO AND SHASTA COUNTIES
THE PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS WERE
AMPLIFIED. HIS MANY OF THE THEIR
AREAS CATER TO TOURISTS ARE
EITHER VISIT VISITORS PASSING
THROUGH. COUNTIES WITH SMALLER
PA. THAT ARE HIGHLY BECAUSE OF
TOURIST ATTRACTIONS IT
ADDITIONAL GOODS AND SERVICES TO
MEET THE DEMAND INCLUDING MORE
FOOD AND BEVERAGE VENDORS OR
LICENSES WITH MORE LICENSE WILL
HELP. MEET THAT DEMAND S. B. F.
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL DO JUST
THAT BY ALLOWING THE ABC TO
ISSUE TEN NEW GENERAL LICENSES
EACH FOR ELDORADO AND SHASTA
COUNTIES. SO THEY CAN IMPROVE
THE SUCCESS IN THEIR FOOD
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS MEET THE
GROWING NEEDS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES. A REAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE UNIQUE CHALLENGES SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY TO HELP ADDRESS
ONE OF THOSE CHALLENGES GIVING
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT EL DORADO
AND SHASTA COUNTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY GROW- I DO NOT HAVE-
REGISTERED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF MY BILL IN THE DO IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME THE CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU US DAHLE- SO
WE'RE MOVE DIRECT TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR WE SEE- IF ANY
SO. ON THE LINES FOR SB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO. YES THANK
YOU AND YOUR SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FOUR FIVE TWO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY THAT'S
ONE ZERO APPEARANCE. AND IT IS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR- CAN WE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ON THE PHONE LINES I
BEING DONE IN THE CHAMBERS. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME AND THAT'S ONE
ZERO OPPOSITION. AND CURRENTLY
WE HAVE NO FAULT THANK YOU. WELL
DONE SENATOR DOLLY- DO OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FIFTY NINE CENTER
DOLLY WHICH WHAT I'M SORRY
SENATE CENTER WHICH SAID YOU
HAVE YOUR BACK UP AGAINST SOME
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO FEDERAL DOLLARS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BACK FASTER NAY
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE
A BILL SB FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR HUESO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
MANDATORY SHINS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI. ALLEN ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BAKER
GORGEOUS. BORDERS FIVE BRADFORD
GLAZER GLAZER AYE WESSEL HUESO
AYE JONES JONES HI KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK.
WILK HI. NINE ZERO ON CALL NINE
ZERO PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL WE'RE
COMING UP TO OUR LAST BILL WE'RE
WAITING ON SENATOR MCGUIRE ALL
MEMBERS- THEY NEED TO- PUT THEIR
VOTES IN ON THE PREVIOUS BILLS
NEED TO. COME TO THE CHAMBERS
IMMEDIATELY.
AND SENATOR MCGUIRE IS HERE IN
THE HOUSE. SENATE MCGUIRE WHEN
YOU ARE READY YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR BREATH
HEY THERE WE GO EXACTLY AS I
CAN'T UNDERNEATH THE MASK. WELL
FIRST AND FOREMOST I MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- TREMENDOUS
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL. THAT
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE STAFF OF FOR THE
FANTASTIC WORK. MISTER CHAIR I
THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE. THE
WORLD IS WATCHING THE ATROCITIES
TAKING PLACE IN UKRAINE EACH AND
EVERY DAY WITH **** IT'S
SICKENING. MAKES ME ANGRY
OUTRAGED. INCREDIBLY SAD. RUSSIA
HAS CAN HAS COMMENCED UNPROVOKED
DIVERSITY MORE IN UKRAINE THAT
IS CAUSE INDISCRIMINATE KILLING
OF CIVILIANS BOMBING OF WHOLE
CITIES THE DISLOCATION OF
MILLIONS OF REFUGEES IN
MONUMENTAL DESTRUCTION TO
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS. I THINK
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE WE HAVE TO
STAND WITH THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE
AND THAT'S WHY SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT IS A CRITICAL BILL
THAT'S REQUIRING PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEMS INCLUDING THE TWO
LARGEST IN AMERICA RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THURS IN PERS TO
DIVEST FROM RUSSIAN AND
BELARUSIAN ASSETS AND COMPANIES
IN FACT. X. DO SO MANY OF YOU IN
THIS ROOM TODAY STIRS IN PERS
HAS OFFICIALLY STARTED.
DIVESTING THEIR INVESTMENTS IN
RUSSIA BUT WE MUST FINISH THE
JOB. S. MOBILIZED TO STOP THESE
INDISCRIMINATE RUSSIAN ATTACKS.
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY NOT EVEN IN THE
TOP TEN OF WORLD ECONOMIES IS
ONE OF THEIR BIG PRESSURE POINTS
IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD USE OUR
POWER TO EXERT INFLUENCE WHERE
WE CAN DO IT FOR GOOD. IT'S
BELIEVE THAT PRIOR TO THE
INVASION RUSSIAN INVESTMENTS UP
FROM STIRS IN PARIS REPROACHING
TWO BILLION DOLLARS SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT ASKS ALSO ASKED
PRIVATE COMPANIES BASED IN
CALIFORNIA TO DIVEST THEIR
INVESTMENTS IN THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY. THAT'S THE NO SAY MR
KERR'S THIS THIS BILL IS
BIPARTISAN I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SO MANY IN THIS ROOM
INCLUDING SHERMAN DIED SOONER
BACKER CENTER BOARD YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO AND CENTER RUBIO FOR
ALL CO AUTHORS ON THIS MEASURE
IN BETWEEN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY FIFTY SEVEN MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE SIGNED ON.
TO BE ABLE TO STAND WITH THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE BRITNEY
BARZANI ON FROM THE CALLOUS
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK CENTER MCGUIRE-
MISPERCEIVED- HERE. THE CHAMBER
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR- THANK YOU FOR TIME BARS
TO CAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR
REQUIRES SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT RELATING TO THE
DIVESTMENT- FROM RUSSIA AND
BELARUS. C. M. K. REPRESENTS
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
PUBLICATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CONTINUOUSLY
FIGHTS TO PROTECT JOURNALISTS.
AND THE CRITICAL ROLE OF THE
PRESS AND COMMUNICATING THE
TRUTH TO THE PUBLIC. ON MANY
ISSUES INCLUDING THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN RUSSIA AND
THE CHALLENGING SPREAD OF
DISINFORMATION ABOUT THE EVENTS
IN THE UKRAINE- AB- AND EVEN
HERE AT HOME IN SACRAMENTO- WE
HAVE SEEN ALEX KARRAS LOST KEYS
RELATIVES WHO GAVE IT HE GAVE AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE SACRAMENTO
BEE AND HIS RELATIVES ARE NOW
BEING DETAINED BY RUSSIANS AS
RETALIATION FOR HEAD EXPERIMENT
OF SIZING HIS FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS. VERY TROUBLING AND SO THAT
C. M. K. SANDS IN STRONG
SOLITARY WITH PEOPLE OF UKRAINE
AND SUPPORTS THE HARDWORKING
JOURNALISTS REPORTING ON THESE
ISSUES M. AND ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE WHO ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO DELIVER THE NEWS WHEN
WE NEED IT THE MOST FOR ALL
THESE REASONS SEE MPA SUPPORTS
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THIS
PERSONALITY. I NOW WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
OF SKEWS ME WE DO- WE DO HAVE.
ELSE THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY HERE
THE CHAMBERS PLEASE WAS THE- WE
- LET'S LINE UP UP THERE SO THAT
WE ALL I COULD SEE OKAY GREAT
LET'S MOVE. MISTER SEA MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL THE
ISRAELIS. BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF BEVERLY HILLS AND SANTA
MONICA AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M JUST RETURNING ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND MY TRAINING FAMILY
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. IS THAT IT UP
THERE. OKAY MODERATOR LET'S OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONCE UNITS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE SUPPORT. TWENTY
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS BILL MURPHY FROM.
THREE FIFTY TOTAL VALLEY ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA AND
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT. SILICON
VALLEY IN SUPPORT AND I ALSO
WANT TO ADD A PERSONAL NOTE THE
UKRAINIAN AMERICAN THAT I AM
PERSONALLY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE. THANK YOU. ANOTHER
WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS THAT
HERE FROM OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE
SEEING NONE- OPERATOR WERE
MOVING NOW TO FOUR WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ARMORS. IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT. ASIAMATCHONLINE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
CONSIDER WHAT THE TIME. ONCE
IT'S ONE ZERO OPPOSITE. AT THIS
TIME I HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU. WE'LL BRING THIS
DOUBT BACK TO- MEMBERS ANYBODY
WISHING TO ADDRESS. CENTER
BORDERS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
COLLEAGUES I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
SEEN. BILLS NOT TOO DISSIMILAR
TO THIS ABOUT. POSING PENSION
DIVESTMENT AND- OTHER MEANS OF-
WITHDRAWING CALIFORNIA'S FOR
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AND I KNOW
THAT SOME FOLKS AREN'T ARE
NATURALLY HESITANT THAT WE ARE
INVOLVING INTERNATIONAL FEARS
INTO THE JURISDICTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT I WOULD
CAUTION. THAT THAT THAT KIND OF
DEFAULT THINKING IS APPROPRIATE
HERE. THERE ARE CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES- THAT WE HAVE SEEN
ON THE GLOBAL STAGE THAT REQUIRE
OUR ATTENTION. THEY REQUIRE US
TO ACT JUST AS AMERICA'S ACTING
AND EUROPE IS ACTING AND PARTS
OF ASIA OR ACTING. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CALL OUT WHAT
IS BEING DONE IN UKRAINE. IT IS
SPECIFICALLY AND SPECIFICALLY
WHAT IS BEING DONE BY THE
RUSSIAN BY RUSSIAN LEADERSHIP.
NO I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
WELL OUR FIGHT IS NOT WITH THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE. IT IS TAKING
GREAT. CLAIM AGAINST RUSSIAN
LEADERSHIP IN PARTICULAR THE
PRESS. THE IS ACE. ON THE GROUND
IN IN ON THE SCALE OF THINGS
THIS IS A SMALL BUT TERRIBLY
SYMBOLIC GESTURE THAT WE SHOULD
BE MAKING IS CALIFORNIANS IF WE
HAVE WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION OUR
PENSION AND OTHER TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS. ARE THAT WE CAN
BRING TO BEAR IT AS PART OF A
SANCTIONS PROGRAM WE MUST DO IT
IT'S A MORAL IMPERATIVE SO I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS. HI THIS
A LETTER- I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT ONE PROVISION- ALLOWS IT IS
TO BE WITHDRAWN OR REPEALED AS
SOON AS THE RUSSIANS STALTER
HOLD THIRD VANCE- I WOULD I
WOULD. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
WE NOT HAVE THAT PROVISION IN
THERE- BECAUSE UNTIL RUSSIA NOT
ONLY HOLDS ITS ADVANCE BUT
WITHDRAWS FROM ALL OCCUPIED
TERRITORIES AND MAKES AN
FINANCIAL A MAN'S- OF FOR ALL OF
THE DAMAGE THEY HAVE DONE. SO
THAT IS A PERFECT WORLD I WON'T
INSIST ON THAT ONE POINT BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD AND I WANT TO- CALL
UPON OUR COLLEAGUES. LET
CALIFORNIA'S BE HEARD. AND MAKE
IT RELEVANT IN FINANCIALLY THIS
IS A RELEVANT GESTURE IN SUPPORT
OF UKRAINE. THANK YOU CENTER
BORDERS I THINK THAT'S A STRONG
POINT ACTUALLY ABSENT A RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I ALSO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT AND IS A
CO AUTHOR OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE U. K. U.
CRANING COMMUNITY ALONG WITH
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE AS
ALREADY STATED. NO ONE I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM HELL
SPREAD FROM BRINGING THIS
URGENCY BILL FORWARD- I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CALL
OUT. A CORRUPT REGIME AND I
THINK THIS IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
THIS IS ABOUT HUMANITY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS ALL OF US
VERY PERSONALLY. AND THE TRAUMA
AND THE VIOLENCE THAT THIS WAR
IS GOING TO CAUSE IS GONNA BE
FELT FOR GENERATIONS TO COME AND
WE CANNOT STAND SILENT AS WE SEE
SOME OF THE CHILDREN ARE AND
WHAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING NOT
ONLY WHAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
BUT SOME OF THE MURDERS THAT THE
SCENE AND I. ONCE AGAIN I STAND
IN STRONG SOLIDARITY WITH THE
UKRAINIAN COMMUNITY AND ALSO
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SUTTER NIELSEN. THE PRESENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
I WISH TO BRING A MORE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS. IN THIS
REGION THERE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND EASTERN EUROPEANS WHO
CAME HERE TO SETTLE. THEY CAME
HERE WHEN THE WALL CAME DOWN.
AND THEY CAME TO AMERICA. THEY
CAME TO AMERICA. TO BE AMERICANS
THE KIM NATURALIZED AND
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. INDEED THERE'S MORE
FREEDOM IN SOME OF THOSE
COUNTRIES NOW THAT THEY- LEFT.
BUT HERE WE HAVE A CLASSIC
EXAMPLE. OF THE NATION'S
LEADERSHIP WHO HAS NO SHAME. BUT
ONLY A LAST IN QUEST FOR POWER.
BUT IT BODES ILL FOR THE WORLD
AND PARTICULARLY FOR AMERICA. IF
WE DO NOT SPEAK OUT LOUDLY. SUCH
LET LEGISLATION IS THIS FOR
RESOLUTIONS. HAVE PROBABLY MINOR
IMPACT ON THE COURSE OF HUMAN
EVENTS. OVER THE DECADES WE'VE
HAD MANY HERE. BUT I WOULD ARGUE
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT. WHY BECAUSE THIS ONE
. IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM. AND
PRESERVING IT. AND WE DO NOT
STAND UP. WE WILL BE AFFECTED.
THERE ARE EVENTS CLOSE AT THE
HEELS OF JUST ONE TO FOLLOW.
THANK OF TAIWAN. COMMUNIST CHINA
. WILL MOVE NEXT. AMERICA CANNOT
STAND SILENT. FROM OUR PRESIDENT
ALL THE WAY HERE TOO SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M GONNA TELL
YOU A STORY. THE LINGS IN MY
HEART AND THIS ONE OF THESE
EASTERN EUROPEANS. I HAVE A LOT
OF RONALD REAGAN STORIES IN. I
WAS TELLING SOME OF ONE NIGHT AT
AN EVENT. THEN A FELLOW NAMED
LAUREN CENTER TO CREWMEN. CAME
UP TO ME SHOULD SENATOR CAN I
TELL YOU ONE OF MY REAGAN
STORIES I SAID SURE. HE SAID
THAT WHEN REAGAN. WENT ON TV AND
SAID MR GORBACHEV TAKE DOWN THAT
WALL. I WAS IN CHANGE. IN A
PRISON AND BELGRADE YUGOSLAVIA
THE POLITICAL PRISONER. AND THE
GUARDS HAD THE TV ON AND WE
HEARD THOSE WORDS. AND HAVE A
MOMENT OF HOPE. SENATOR TWO
MONTHS LATER I WAS IN CHANGE. IN
THE OFFICE OF THE UNITED STATES
AMBASSADOR IN BELGRADE
YUGOSLAVIA. IN THE BASSINGER
SAID. TAKE OFF THOSE CHANGE.
LAUREN THEN CAME HERE AND IS A
PART OF THAT GLORIOUS. A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. MANY OF THESE THAT I
SPEAK OF. HAVE A FAMILY. IN
FRENCH IN THIS THREATEN THE
NATION. I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SONOMA COUNTY. WE'RE GIVING
US THE OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THE SPEAK OUR-
SMALL BUT NOT AND CONSEQUENT
PIECE. SUPPORTING THE PEOPLE OF
THE UKRAINE. CALL CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU THIS YEAR I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF IT SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS A
CHAIR OF MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE. AND I WILL TELL YOU
ALL THAT OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM. ARE THERE SOME ARE ON
STANDBY BUT THEY ARE READY TO
GIVE THEIR LIVES. AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE REALIZED THAT WE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
BOTH SOMETIMES THAT WE'RE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. WELL LET'S PUT THE ACTION
ON THE TABLE. LET'S DO SOMETHING
AND SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS ACTUALLY TAKING US
THROUGH THAT FIRST STEP WHERE WE
CAN ALL STAND CALIFORNIANS SAY
THAT WE'VE DONE SOMETHING. IT
MAY NOT BE LARGE BUT I TELL YOU
WHAT IT IS SOMETHING TO SHOW THE
SUPPORT TO OUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE SERVING READY TO GO. AND I
TELL YOU THAT THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY I STRENGTH A STAND
STRONG SUPPORT. PLEASE ALL OF US
LET'S GET BEHIND SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. AND I
URGE AND I WILL. THANK YOU SIR
ARE. SENATOR HUESO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO BUT- IT'S AN
EASY THING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND- I WANT TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR FROM NOT ALREADY A CO
AUTHOR AND JUST SIMPLY STATE
THAT- I AM LIKE MANY OF YOU AND
MANY OF THE REST OF THE WORLD I
AM OUTRAGED BY WHAT'S HAPPENING
. AND IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE THE
SHOW OF SUPPORT ACROSS OUR
STATE. EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE HAD. PEOPLE
COME OUT HIS SOLIDARITY WITH
UKRAINE. I HAD A CHANCE TO STUDY
THERE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF THE
DESKSIDE. AND I LEARNED- SPEAK
LITTLE RUSSIAN THERE. AND IT WAS
A WONDERFUL COMMUNITY THEY'RE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE. I SAW SO MANY
SIMILARITIES TO MY OWN CULTURE.
AND THE PEOPLE THEY'RE VERY
INVITING THE VERY HOSPITABLE
VERY WARM. AND IT JUST PAINS ME
SO MUCH TO SEE SO MANY FAMILIES
STRUGGLING IN AND SUFFERING AND
JUST THE SENSELESS LOSS OF LIFE
THAT IT'S COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY
BUT FOR ONE PERSON'S- JUST
ABSOLUTE MENTAL ILLNESS. SO I. I
HOPE THAT WE- SEND A VERY STRONG
STATEMENT INTERNATIONALLY AND
HOPEFULLY THE REST OF THE- OF
THE OTHER FIFTY STATES ARE DOING
SOMETHING IN THIS REGARD AS
WELL. ATARA YELLOW BLUE BOOK
ARANEA. THANK YOU CENTER HUESO
SENATE MCGUIRE BEFORE YOU CLOSE
I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL AND TAKING
THE LEAD ON THIS WITH NEARLY NOW
NEARLY SIXTY CO AUTHORS FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO HAVE
TAKEN A STAND AGAINST THE
UNPROVOKED INVASION OF UKRAINE.
THE IMAGES AND VIDEOS OF
FAMILIES BEING TORN APART BY
THIS SENSELESS ACT OF VIOLENCE
ARE HEARTBREAKING AND YET THE
STORIES OF EVERYDAY MEN AND
WOMEN FIGHTING FOR THEIR
FREEDOM. IS INSPIRING TO US ALL.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD CALIFORNIA MUST DO ITS
PART IN SUPPORTING PRESIDENT
PHILIP SKI. AND THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE. WE MUST SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
DO BUSINESS WITH ANY COMPANY
THAT SUPPORTS THIS NEEDLESS WAR.
I HOPE THIS BILL SENDS THAT
MESSAGE SENATE MCGUIRE WOULD
LIKE CLOSE. REALLY WELL SAID
MISTER CHAIR AND AGAINST YOUR I
WANNA THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
THANK YOU SO I THINK THAT THE
THANK YOU THAT I NEED TO GIVE
TODAY'S EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU. FOR SAY THANK YOU TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT WHEN
I SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIRMAN
DODD. CENTER BAKER CENTER BOARD
JUST IN A PARTICULAR
PORTANTINO'S AND RUBIO FOR THEIR
COOPER SHOULD POLICY THANK YOU
CENTER TO LONDON CENTER WAY SO.
WILL BE JOINING US ON THIS
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT MISSION ON
IT RIGHT HERE. STATES ACROSS
AMERICA ALMOST EVERY STATE
ACROSS THIS NATION ARE
DEVASTATING THEIR INTERESTS. IN
RUSSIA. CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT.
INVESTMENTS APPROACHING. NEARLY
TWO BILLION PRIOR TO THE WAR. IT
IS TIME. TO PUT OUR ECONOMIC
POWER GOOD. INDIA STOP THIS
INVESTMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN MISTER
CHAIR. A CENTER HUESO I ASSUME
THAT THAT WAS YOU CRANIUM FOR I
MOVE THE BILL. DOT OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION- BY SENATOR HUESO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DODD HI DOT HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE ALLEN ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BAKER
BARGES GORGEOUS HIGH BRADFORD
GLAZER GLAZER HI WESO. WESSEL HI
JONES. JONES HI KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO
I WILL. WILK HI. THAT'S TENDER
CHAIRMAN ON CALL IN ZERO THE
BILL'S ON CALL WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE RULES OF THE
MEMBERS HERE CAN LEAVE WHEN THEY
ARE AT THE END OF THIS WERE
WAITING FOR THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO ADJOURN BEFORE- WE
CAN ADJOURN- SO THEIR MEMBERS
WILL COME OVER AND VOTE. SO
LET'S MOVE FIRST- YOU SEE OR
HEAR WELL THEY'LL START WITH
CONSECUTIVE SECRETARY PLEASE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY MEMBERS
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. BALENTINE
BAKER BRADFORD KAMLAGER
PORTANTINO RUBIO RUBIO HI I'M
CULTURE BILL STILL ON CALL. AND. IT THE CONSIST SO NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON A FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
S. B. NINE OH EIGHT. SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FILE ITEM
ONE SB NINE OH EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. ALLEN HI BAKER
BRADFORD KAMLAGER PORTANTINO
RUBIO. RUBIO I AM COCHAIRMAN.
BILLS ON CALL WILL NOW MOVE THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY- SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. ALLEN HI BRADFORD
KAMLAGER PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO
I ON CULTURE THOSE ON CALL WE
WILL NOW MOVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB NINE ELEVEN SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THAT ROLE. ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. ALLEN I BORDERS
BRADFORD PORTANTINO RUBIO RUBIO
AYE THAT'S GOT ABLE TERMINAL
CALL THAT BILLS ON CALL WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR S.
B. TEN TEN SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ABSENT MEMBERS BAKER
BRADFORD KAMLAGER PORTANTINO
RUBIO. RUBIO I FUNDS LARGER
INFLOWS ON CALL NOW WE MOVED TO-
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN
NINETY SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BACKER BRADFORD
KAMLAGER. PORTANTINO RUBIO.
RUBIO I ON CALL ON CALL WILL NOW
MOVE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN S.
B. TWELVE EIGHTY SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. AT BURLINGTON SB
TWELVE EIGHTY ABSENT MEMBERS
BACKER BRADFORD KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO
I ON CULTURE AND THOSE ON CALL
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S. B.
THIRTEEN OH FIVE SIXTY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT MEMBERS
BACKER BORDERS BRADFORD KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO
I ON CALL. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS BAKER. BRADFORD KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO. ON CALL WAS
ON CALL. THE MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY TWO AFTER MEMBERS BAKER
BRADFORD DOWN LONGER MELENDEZ
PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO HI I'M
CALLING FROM. OKAY WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A SHORT RECESS UNTIL
THESE MEMBERS- ARE ABLE TO GET
OVER FROM THE OTHER BUILDING- TO
HEAR I DON'T KNOW IF THE
MODERATOR IS STILL ON THE LINE
WELL DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR ALL YOUR HELP IN IN OUR
HEARING TODAY.
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
COMMITTEE. IS BACKED SESSION. WE
WILL NOW LEFT ALL THE CALLS WE
WILL START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY CONTENT CALENDAR ABSENT
MEMBERS BECKER. BAKER HI
BRADFORD REFER I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER AYE PORTANTINO FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT'S OUR OR TEASER OF THE
BILL IS OUT WE MOVED FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB NINE AWAIT
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ABSENT MEMBER BAKER. BAKER AYE
BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD AYE
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER AYE
PORTANTINO. THAT IS TEN TO FOUR
. THEREFORE THE BILL'S OUT WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY THIRTY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER AYE
PORTANTINO. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO. FOLLOW
NUMBER THREE SB NINE ELEVEN
SECRETARY PLEASE OVERALL AFTER
MEMBERS BORDERS BRADFORD
REMEMBERS THIS NOW I'LL- HEY
WHAT. PORTANTINO. ONE AT EIGHTY
FOUR CHAIRMAN AT THE CENTER OF
PROPERTY YOU WANNA. OKAY EIGHTY
FOUR CHAIRMAN THE BILL'S
ADVOCATES FOR THAT BILLS OUT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS P. TEN TEN SECTOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE BAKER. HI
BAKER AYE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
REFER AYE KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
AYE PORTANTINO. THAT'S ELEVEN TO
THREE TERMINATE THOSE OUT LEVIN
TO THREE THAT BILLS OUT WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SB ELEVEN NINETY SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE AFTER MEMBERS
FACTOR. ALL RIGHT BAKER AYE
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER AYE
PORTANTINO FOURTEEN ZERO OF
THOSE ON. FOURTEEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT NUMBER ONE THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS BACKER. HI
BAKER I BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD
AYE KAMLAGER I AM NOT- AYE
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO. THIRTEEN TO
REMEMBER OUR GERMAN AND IT WAS
ON THE TEAM ZERO THAT PULLS OUT
THE NUMBER OF ON THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN OH
FIVE. SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE ABSENT MEMBERS BAKER ALL
RIGHT BAKER I BORDERS BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT BYE FOR HI KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ PORTANTINO.
THAT'S OUT. HOW MANY VOTES
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO
THE BILLS OUT. WE NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT SECTOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS BAKER. ALL RIGHT BAKER
AYE BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD HI
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER AYE
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO TERMINA BILL
ABOUT. THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT. WILL NOW MOVE ON THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY TWO SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE ABSENT MEMBERS BACKER. ALL
RIGHT BAKER AYE BRADFORD AYE
ROUGHER AYE KAMLAGER. HOWEVER I
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO. THIRTEEN
ZERO CHAIRMAN OF THOSE ON YOUR%
TEAM ZERO THAT BILLS OUT I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS-
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT%
ABLE TO TESTIFY. PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS OF
RIDING. THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COOPERATION WE HAVE INCLUDING
THE AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS
ENTERED.